İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 14 Ağustos 2024 çarşamba günü 14. ders günümüz saat 19.30 dersimize başlıyoruz.
Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz. Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
En son kaldığımız yer print bildirimleriydi. Daha hiç sentaksa girmeden print bildiriminin ne olduğundan bahsettik.
Sınıfımızın private bölümüne başka kodların yani doğrudan sınıfın kendi üye fonksiyonları haricinde başka fonksiyonların başka sınıfların erişmesine izin vermek demek.
Ve önce şunu tartıştık. Peki bu programlamanın özellikle nesne yönelimli programlamanın genel ilkelerine aykırı mı?
Tam olarak değil. Çünkü friendlik verdiğimiz aslında sınıfın yine kendi kodları.
Ama nasıl kodları? Örneğin global fonksiyonlar ya da başlık dosyası içinde ya da cpp dosyası içinde bildirilen yardımcı sınıflar.
Friend bildiriminin 3 ayrı biçiminden bahsettik. Global bir fonksiyona friendlik vermek, bir başka sınıfın bir üye fonksiyonuna friendlik vermek ve bir sınıfın tamamına friendlik vermek.
O zaman şimdi bunları görerek başlayalım.
Arkadaşlar şu bizim her zamanki gibi örneklerde kullandığımız sınıflardan biri MyClass sınıfı.
Ve MyClass sınıfı içinde rent anahtar sözcüğünü kullanarak int, foo, int.
Örneğin bu şekilde bir bildirim yaparsak namespace'deki foo isimli fonksiyon geri dönüş değeri int, parametresi int olan MyClass sınıfının bir friendi.
Bu ne demek? Bu fonksiyon içinde sınıfın private bölümüne erişimi derleyici bir sentaks hatası olarak değerlendirmeyecek.
Yani örneğin derleyici bu bildirimi gördükten sonra bu fonksiyonun bildirimiyle karşılaşırsa, tanımı ile karşılaşırsa, bu fonksiyonun tanımı içinde parametre değişkeni yoluyla ya da yerel değişkenler yoluyla,
bunlar pointer olabilir, referans olabilir, sınıf nesnesinin doğrudan kendisi olabilir, sınıfın private bölümüne erişim sentaks hatası olarak değerlendirilmeyecek.
Sınıfın örneğin private bölümünde mx isimli bir veri elemanı ve bar isimli private bir fonksiyon olsun.
Frenk bildirimini kapatıyorum, kapatıyorum derken yorum satırını alıyorum, derleyicinin görmesini engelliyorum ve önce MyClass sınıfı türünden bir değişken tanımladım ve bu değişken yoluyla mx'ine eriştim.
Tabii ki erişim kontrolüne takıldı ya da m.bar biçiminde bir çağrı yaptım, erişim kontrolüne takıldı.
Oysa Frenk bildirimini derleyici görseydi gördüğünüz gibi bir sentaks hatası olmayacaktı.
Böylece örneğin başlık dosyasında bildirilen sınıfın müşteri kodlarına, client kodlarına hizmet veren böyle fonksiyonlar sınıfın private bölümüne erişebilecek.
Evet, şimdi burada aklınıza gelecek sorulardan biri arkadaşlar, dersi kaydetmeye izin verilmiyor kayıt talibinde bulunan arkadaşlarım için özellikle söylüyorum.
Burada akla gelebilecek sorulardan biri şu, Frenk bildirimi sınıfın hangi bölümünde yapılıyor?
Bu ne fark ettiriyor?
Yani örneğin sınıfın private bölümünde Frenk bildirimini yapsaydım ne fark ederdi?
Tahminde bulunmak isteyen var mı?
Cevap, eğer tahminde bulunmak isteyen hiç kimse yoksa bilenler söylemesin.
Cevap, hiçbir şey fark etmezdi.
Yani bir bildirimin sınıfın hangi bölümünde yapılmasının herhangi bir farklı etki oluşturmadığı sayılı senaryolardan biri Frenk bildirimi.
İster public bölümde yapın, ister protected bölümde yapın, ister private bölümde yapın değişen bir şey olmayacak.
İşte bu Frenk bildiriminin birinci biçimi.
Ve arkadaşlar, Frenk bildiriminin böyle fonksiyonlara Frenk'e verdiğimiz zaman, namespace'deki fonksiyonlara ilginç ve ileride mercek altına alacağımız çok önemli bir özelliği daha var.
Hatta bu özelliğe ya da bu özellikten kaynaklanan idiomatik yapıya verilen bir isim var.
Belki duymuş olabilir C++'da kod yazan arkadaşlarım.
Hidden Frenk.
Bunu ileride açıklayacağım.
Hidden Frenk ya da Hidden Frenk.
Arkadaşlar, birçok durumda sınıfın Frenk fonksiyonlarını, dilin kuralları da buna izin veriyor, doğrudan sınıf içinde tanımlayabilirim.
Yok, çağrı sizden gelmedi, başka bir arkadaşımdan geldi, önemli değil.
Belki ilk defa katılıyor olabilir.
Yani Frenk fonksiyonunun tanımını, inline olarak sınıfın içinde yapabilirim.
Bu şimdiye kadar gördüğümüz senaryoların biraz dışında, değil mi?
Çünkü şimdiye kadar biz sınıfın statik ya da non-statik üye fonksiyonlarını sınıfın içinde tanımlayabiliyorduk.
Ama sınıfın doğrudan kendi üye fonksiyonu olmasa da, Frenk fonksiyonları sınıfın içinde tanımlayabiliyoruz.
Ve namespace konusu ve ADL söz konusu olduğunda, operatör overloading konusunda tamamladığımızda, bunun belki ileride önemi üstünde konuşacağız.
Evet, peki o zaman buradan çıkan üç kural, Frenk bildirimi bir Free Function için yapılabilir.
Frenk bildiriminin sınıfın hangi bölümünde yapıldığının etkisi üstünde bir sonucu yok.
Ve Free olan arkadaşlar, fonksiyona Frenk verdiğimizde bunu Class Definition için de tanımlayabiliyoruz.
Burada inline anahtar sözcüğünü kullanalım mı?
Hayır, yine fonksiyon implicit ile inline ama kullanmanızın da bir etkisi yok.
Şimdi ikinci senaryo, yani benim yazdığım sıraya göre ikinci senaryo,
Aslında bunların içinde en az kullanılan senaryo, bir başka sınıfın bir üye fonksiyonuna Frenk'lik vermek.
Arkadaşlar, burada bir şey daha dikkatinizi çekmeli.
Bu şekilde bir Frenk bildirimi yaptığım zaman, derleyicinin daha önce bu fonksiyonun bildirimi ya da tanımıyla karşılaşması gerekmiyor.
Yani bu konu derlediğim zaman gördüğünüz gibi bir sentaks hatası yok.
Derleyici şöyle demedi, iyi de ben böyle bir fonksiyonun bildirimini görmedim ya da tanımını görmedim.
Yani buradaki isim için Frenk bildiriminde bir isim arama süreci gerçekleştirmiyor.
Fakat ikinci Frenk bildirimi için, yani bir sınıfın bir üye fonksiyonuna yapılacak Frenk bildirimi için sınıfın tanımını görmek zorunda.
Yani örneğin şöyle yazamayız.
Frenk, int, bu ama kimin fulsu?
Örneğin ne cisimle sınıfın fulsu?
Gördüğünüz gibi, derleyicimiz bu durumu sentaks hatası olarak değerlendirdi.
Peki, Necati, forward declaration yaparak bunu geçerli hale getirebilir miyiz?
Yani şöyle yazsak geçerli mi?
Hayır, fonksiyonun tanımı içinde, özür dilerim sınıfın tanımı içinde bu fonksiyonun bildirimini görmek zorunda.
Yani örneğin şöyle olsaydı, class-nec, int, nec, bu, arkadaşlar, int, nec, bu diyorum özür dilerim, int, bu, değil mi? Tamam.
Şimdi bakın, bir sentaks hatası yok.
Şimdi ben bu fonksiyonu tanımladığım noktada, tanımı tipik olarak sınıftan sonra olacak.
İsterseniz tanımlayalım, int, nec sınıfının full fonksiyonu ve bu fonksiyonun içinde örneğin my class sınıfı türünden bir nesne oluşturalım.
Ve az önce olduğu gibi, m.mx'i ve m.bar isimlerini kullanalım.
Derleyicinin arkadaşlar, bir, bakalım, friend int, nec, bu.
Evet, tabii şunu da public yapalım.
Evet, şimdi tekrar bakalım.
Sınıfın public bölümünde geri dönüş değeri int olan nec sınıfının full fonksiyonuna friend bildirimi yapıldı.
İşte bu nec sınıfının int geri dönüşlü full fonksiyonu ve sınıfın private bölümüne erişebildiğini görüyorsunuz.
Üçüncü friend bildirimi bu nadiren karşımıza çıkacak.
Necati sınıfın special member fonksiyonlarına friendlik verebilir miyim?
Evet, evet.
Yani bu sınıfın herhangi bir üye fonksiyonu için geçerli bir durum.
Yani bu pekala learning constructor olabilir ya da copy constructor olabilir, copy assignment olabilir.
Onlara da friendlik verebilirsiniz.
Üçüncüsü, yine sık kullanılan bir friend bildirimi.
Ve bu sefer bakınız, friend, class, nec.
Bu friendlik bildiriminin önce doğrudan sentaks hatası olmadığını görün.
Yani derleyici bu friend bildirimini geçerli kabul etmek için nec sınıfının daha önce bir bildiriminin ya da tanımının olmasını şart korkmuyor.
Artık daha sonra bu bildiriminin görüldüğü bir noktada nec sınıfının herhangi bir üye fonksiyonu içinde myclass sınıfının private bölümüne erişilebilecek.
Bu daha sonra görülen class nec olsun ve necin arkadaşlar örneğin u fonksiyonu içinde ya da necin bar fonksiyonu içinde herhangi bir üye fonksiyonu içinde statik ya da non-statik myclass sınıfı türünden m, m.mx herhangi şekilde bir sentaks hatası oluşturulabilir.
Ya da m.bar bir sentaks hatası oluşturulmayacak.
Ama bu sadece fonksiyonu için değil necin diğer fonksiyonları içinde geçerli.
Örneğin necin hangisinin bir fonksiyonu olsaydı yine bir sentaks hatası olmayacaktı.
Yani böyle bir bildirimle sınıfın tamamına friend bildirimi yapmış oluyoruz.
Sınıfın bütün üye fonksiyonları myclass sınıfının private bölümüne erişebilir demek.
Arkadaşlar şimdi friendlikle ilgili bir iki tane yine önemli kuraldan bahsedelim.
Ama buraya şöyle de bir not düşelim.
Jenerik programlama tarafında friend bildirimleri çok daha karmaşık hale gelecek ve çok daha fazla konuşmamız gerekecek.
Yani şimdilik bu jenerik programlama tarafını pas geçiyoruz.
Jenerik sınıfları, sınıf şablonları benim tabirimde İngilizce kullanılan terim, class template ve function template onları yok sayıyoruz.
Jenerik programlama ayrı bir bölüm olarak karşımıza çıkacak kursta.
Evet şimdi friend bildirimiyle ilgili bir iki tane temel bir kısmını belki Sezgi ile zaten doğrudan tahmin edebileceğiniz bir kısmı önemli olabilecek ileride üç tane kural.
Arkadaşlar A sınıfı, B sınıfına friend bildirimi yapsın.
A sınıfı arkadaşlar B sınıfına friend bildirimi yapsın.
Yani kafanızı canlandırın.
Class A, friend class B.
B sınıfı da A sınıfına friendlik vermiş olmuyor.
Yani burada değişme özelliği yok.
Yani bu ne demek?
B, A'nın private bölümüne erişebilir.
Ama belki şöyle bir beklentisi olan olabilir.
A, madem ben B'ye friendlik verdim o zaman ben de B'nin private bölümüne erişirim.
Hayır böyle bir durum söz konusu değil.
Burayı anladık mı?
A'nın B'ye friendlik vermesi karşılığında otomatik olarak B'nin de A'ya friendlik vermesi anlamına gelmiyor.
Ben karşı cinsinden biriyle arkadaş olmak istiyorum.
Ona arkadaşlık bildirimi yaptım.
Ama ondan yine arkadaşlık bildirimi aldığım anlamına gelmiyor.
Değil mi?
Bu bir.
İkincisi arkadaşlar.
Bu da önemli.
Geçişken de değil.
Transitif de değil.
Bu ne demek?
Bu da daha önemli belki.
A, B'ye friendlik vermiş olsun.
B'de C'ye friendlik vermiş olsun.
Yani A, B'ye diyor ki sen benim private bölümüne erişebilirsin diyor.
B'de C'ye diyor ki sen de benim private bölümüne erişebilirsin.
Peki C, A'nın private bölümüne erişebilir mi?
Fatih Akgül, Yusuf Furkan Doğan cevap hayır.
İngilizce'de böyle durumlarda kullanılan terim transitivity böyle bir geçişkenlik yok.
Arkadaşlar son olarak nereye analoji yapmaya çalıştığımı tahmin edebilecek misiniz?
Babanızın, dedenizin arkadaşları sizin arkadaşlarınız mıdır?
Cevap, not necessarily, çoğunlukla hayır.
Burada da göndermeyi nereye yapıyorum tahmin edin?
Kalıtım konusuna.
Bravo Fatih.
Inheritans.
Ama Necati daha Inheritans, kalıtım ya da biraz daha eski tabirli miras konusunu görmedik.
İleride göreceğiz ama şimdi not düşelim.
Bu ne demek arkadaşlar?
Örneğin, A sınıfı ya da orada kullanacağımız terminolojiyle B sınıfı, Nec sınıfına frendlik vermiş olsun.
Ve biz daha sonra öğreneceğimiz, bazı arkadaşlarımız için çok yeni olabilir, kursun en kapsamlı bölümlerinden biri olacak kalıtım.
B sınıfından, D sınıfını kalıtım yoluyla elde etmiş olalım.
O zaman arkadaşlar, D sınıfı da Nec sınıfına arkadaşlık vermiş oluyor mu?
Yoksa Nec sınıfı sadece Beys'in private bölümüne mi erişebilir, yoksa hem Beys'in hem Der'in private bölümlerine erişebilir mi?
Birincisi, Nec bu durumda Der'in private bölümüne erişemez.
Frend bildirimleriyle ilgili ilginç bir durum daha var.
Şöyle bir şey yapmak doğrudan mümkün mü arkadaşlar?
Mesela, My Class isimli bir sınıf olsun ve My Class sınıfının birden fazla örneğin private fonksiyonu olsun.
Void, foo, Void, bar, Void, bas.
Ve ben şunu yapmak isteyeyim.
Bir sınıfa, diyelim ki sınıfın ismi Nec olsun, frendlik vermek istiyorum.
Ama bütün private bölümüne değil, private bölümün seçilmiş bir kısmına.
Yani örneğin şunu diyebilir miyim, Nec sınıfı benim private fonksiyonlarımdan fooya, bara erişebilir ama baza ve boma erişemez.
Tahmin etmeye çalıştım, böyle bir bildirim biçimi var mı?
Cevap, hayır.
Hayır, hayır. Using, anahtar sözcüğüyle de böyle bir şey yapmak mümkün değil.
Ama bu bazen ihtiyaç haline gelebiliyor.
Bunu gerçekleştiren doğrudan bir araç yok.
Ama dolaylı olarak idiomatik bazı yapıları kullanarak bunu gerçekleştirmek mümkün.
Bu idiomlara verilen bazı terimler de var.
Hatta birden fazla idiom var.
Fakat en meşhuru, duyan var mı acaba?
Arkadaşlar İngilizce, Kaveh sınıfta mı? Bakalım.
Evet, Kaveh belki duymuş olabilirsiniz diye söylüyorum.
Atörni Client idiomu deniyor.
İleride belki ben normalde ileri C++ kursumda anlatıyorum.
Ama vaktimiz olursa Atörni Client idiomunu da öğrenmekte fayda var.
Arkadaşlar, Cengiz Han sizin duymuş olduğunuzdan zaten eminim.
Cengiz Han bayağı C++'da ileri düzeyde gördüğüm kadarıyla.
Evet.
It's a design pattern, isn't it?
Diyor Kaveh.
Şimdi design pattern'ı ne anlamda kullandığınıza bağlı.
İsterseniz biraz da Kaveh'in sorusuna cevap olacak.
Şöyle küçük bir sohbet yapalım.
Arkadaşlar, şimdi bazı terimler böyle genel herkesin yüzde yüz kabullendiği terimler değil.
Mesela idiom ne demek?
Pattern ne demek?
Teknik.
Tabii şöyle yazılan teknikten bahsediyorum arkadaşlar.
Yazabilirsek.
Evet.
Ne demek?
Idiom, pattern, teknik.
Şimdi üç tane teorisyene, akademisyene ya da C++ developer'a sorsanız,
yani nelerden bahsettiğimizi 3 aşağı 5 yukarı bize tarif eder.
Ama aralarındaki ayrım biraz da bu terimleri kullanana bağlı.
Yani ben farklı kişilerin farklı anlamda kullandıklarını görebiliyorum.
O yüzden benim verdiğim tanımı yüzde yüz benimsemek zorunda değilsiniz.
Hani bir başkası biraz farklı bir şekilde tanım verirse Necati'yi suçlamayın.
Arkadaşlar, idiom derken aslında belki de en ayırıcı kısım programlama diline bağlı olması.
Yani başka bir programlama dilinde o kalıpsal yapıyı arkadaşlar kullanmak mümkün olmayabilir.
Yani idiom dile ilişkin.
Ki şöyle kitaplar ya da kitaplar var.
Hatta bir tanesi wiki'de serbest C++ idioms diye.
C++ dilinin idiomları.
Burada idiom ne anlamda kullanılıyor?
Yani alıplaşmış çok sayıda programcının arkadaşlar kodu daha iyi hale getirmek için bazen küçük bir kodsal probleme çözüm olsun diye kullandığı kodsal yapılar.
Yani ben eğer konumuz bu olsaydı abartmıyorum sakın abarttığımı düşünmeyin.
En az 50 tane C++ idiomunu size anlatabilirdim.
Bunu şu anlamda söylemiyorum.
Vay be ben neler biliyorum.
Hayır hayır.
Yani üretimde kullanılan çok fazla arkadaşlar idiom var.
Pattern deyince ben Türkçe'de, Türkçe'de birden fazla terim kullanılıyor.
Benim tercih ettiğim terim örüntü.
Ama doğrudan pattern var.
İngilizce sözcüğünün Türkçeleştirilmiş hali kullananlar var arkadaşlar.
Efendim kalıp diyenler var.
Desen diyenler var.
Ben İngilizcesini kullanacağım ileride.
Şablon diyenler var.
Bravo Fatih.
Pattern dendiği zaman çoğunlukla dilden bağımsız.
Mesela nesne yönelimli programlamadaki tasarım kalıpları.
Design Patterns.
Arkadaşlar mesela işte o meşhur Gov kitabında Gang of Four diye geçiyor.
Gov patternleri.
Bunlar dilden bağımsız.
Yani bir programcıya özellikle nesne yönelimli programlama tarafında olan bir programcıya
Observer Pattern'ı ne diye sorarsanız
o Java'da kod yazıyor olsa da C++'da da kod yazıyor olsa
size eğer biliyorsa Observer Pattern'ının
gözlemci diye belki Türkçe'ye çevirebiliriz.
Ne olduğunu anlatabilir, açıklayabilir.
İşte geçen bana sorulan sorulardan biri de buydu Telegram grubunda.
Diğer sınıfta belki Singleton Pattern'ı.
İşte Anti Pattern mi, değil mi vesaire bunun tartışması.
Demek ki pattern daha çok dilden bağımsız bir yapıya işaret ediyor.
Teknik ise arkadaşlar, teknik ise aslında biraz ne diyelim kişiye göre değişebilen bir sözcük.
Ben şu anlamda kullanıyorum.
İdiomlar biraz daha küçük ama dile bağlı yine.
Fakat biraz daha fazla kod gerektiren,
hatta bazen birden fazla kaynak dosyanın da içine girebileceği yapılar.
O yüzden kesin bir ayrım yok.
Mesela rayı idiyom mu?
Valla bence idiyom arkadaşlar.
Ama aynı zamanda bir teknik.
Evet, mesela bazıları doğurman zaten idim sözcüğüyle tanımlanıyor.
Copy, swap idim.
Geçenlerde arkadaşlar bahsetmiştik.
Mesela hidden print idim gibi.
Evet.
Ben bu derimleri bu anlamda kullanıyorum.
Evet, o zaman kahve sizin sorunuzun da cevabı,
ise design pattern bence değil.
Yani bir tasarım kalıbı değil.
Çünkü design pattern dediğiniz zaman adı üstünde tasarımsal bir yapıdan bahsediyoruz.
Mesela şöyle iki tane sınıf oluşturalım.
Bu sınıfla şu sınıf arasındaki ilişkiler şöyle olsun.
Bu sınıftan şu sınıfları inherit edelim vs.
Bu tür yapılardan bahsediyorsak bunlara pattern diyebiliriz ama design pattern diyebiliriz.
Ayrıca da her örüntünün design pattern olması da gerekmiyor.
Yani örneğin bir kodsal yapıdan pattern olarak bahsedebilirim.
Ama o doğrudan design'a, İngilizce karşılığı biz tasarım sözcüğünü kullanıyoruz.
Tasarıma ilişkin olmayabilir.
Evet, hocam ileri CPP kursunda bunlar detaylı olarak işlenecek mi?
Evet, ben özellikle type deduction design pattern diye bir yapı görmüştüm.
CPP'de, bu CPP'yi özel.
Evet, orada çok sayıda idiomu anlatıyorum.
Ama mesela arkadaşlar, type erasure.
Çok güzel bir örnek.
Type erasure bir idiom mu?
Bence değil.
Çünkü idiom demek biraz hafif kalıyor.
Mesela bu bir teknik.
Type erasure.
Çok da sık kullanılan bir teknik.
Ve biraz öğrenmesi de öğretmesi de zor olan tekniklerden biri.
Evet.
Ama çağrı şu doğru.
C++ idiomatik yapı açısından çok zengin bir dil arkadaşlar.
Çünkü dilin çok sayıda aracı olduğu için o araçları İngilizcesi olarak kreatif, yaratıcı bir şekilde kullanıp yeni idiomlar da ortaya çıkıyor.
Bir örnek vereyim.
Sadece örnek olsun diye ileride anlatacağım.
Mesela lambda ifadeleri C++11 ile dile eklendi.
Daha önce lambda expressions yoktu.
Fakat lambda ifadeleri eklendiği zaman ilginç bir şekilde bazı idiomlar, gerçekten bazı developerların buluşu.
Hatta kimin, ben o konuları anlatırken idiomu kimin bulduğunu, kimin ilk defa kullandığını da biliyorsam onu mutlaka söylüyorum.
Mesela pozitif lambda idiğim.
Lambda ifadelerine ilişkin bir idiomatik yapı.
Sadece lambda ifadeleriyle ilgili arkadaşlar 10'a yakın, tam bir sayı vermeyeyim, kullanılan, üretimde kullanılan idiom var.
Neyse biz konuyu çok fazla dağıtmayalım.
Frem bildiriminde en son soruya da cevap vermiş olduk.
Soru şuydu, bir sınıf, bir başka sınıfa private bölümünün tamamı için değil de bir kısmı için fremplik verebilir mi?
Not directly, doğrudan değil.
Ama dolaylı olarak bazı idiomları kullanarak, işte bunların dedik en meşru attorney client dediğim, bu sağlanabilir.
Evet, peki şimdi o zaman frem bildirimlerine şimdilik ara verelim.
Jenerik programlama paradigmasında geri dönmek üzere ve bugünün önemli konusuna bir giriş yapalım.
Sadece bugünün değil, bütün kursun en önemli alt başlıklarından biri.
Çünkü C++ dilinin, gücünün önemli araçlarından biri.
Yani C++ bu araç sayesinde belki diğer dillere göre daha fazla olanağı sahip hale gelecek.
Bahsettiğimiz araç ya da araç seti, geçen derstede söylediğimiz gibi operator overloading.
Şunun tartışmasına girmiyorum.
Çünkü tartışmada çok keskin bir şekilde benim söylediğimin yanlış olduğunu düşünenler de oluyor.
Ama ben function overloading konusunda da söylemiştim.
İngilizce sözcükten bağımsız olarak bana Türkçe'de örneğin function overloading için fonksiyonların aşırı yüklenmesi çok da sık kullanıları oldu.
Ya da operator overloading için operatörlerin aşırı yüklenmesi terimleri beni rahatsız ediyor.
Nedenini de anlatmıştım.
Aşırı iyi bir şey için kullanılacak bir niteleme değil.
Özellikle yeni öğrenenlere fonksiyonların aşırı yüklenmesi, operatörlerin aşırı yüklenmesi diye öğretirseniz onlar sanki kötü bir teknikten, bir programlama hatasından bahsediyormuşuz gibi bir algıya kapılabilirler.
Hem fonksiyon yüklemesi, function overloading hem de operator overloading, operatör yüklemesi dilin en faydalı araçlarından biri.
Arkadaşlar önce makro düzeyde biraz bilgi verelim.
Şimdi dilin bazı araçları var ki bunlar çok seyrek kullanılan araçlar.
Yani bilmeseniz de karşınıza çıktığında biraz çaba gösterip öğrenebilirsiniz.
Hani marjinal diye niteleyebileceğimiz araçlar.
Fakat bazı araçlar var ki dilin ana iskeletinin parçaları, önemli parçaları.
Mesela function overloading öyle.
Operator overloading öyle.
Mesela bir C++ programcısı dese ki ben C++'da çok iyiyim ama operator overloading konusunu pek bilmiyorum.
Mümkün değil böyle bir şey.
Çünkü o kadar çok konumuna bağlı ki.
Demek ki önemli bir araçtan bahsediyoruz.
Marjinal, arada sırada karşımıza çıkacak bir araçtan bahsetmiyoruz.
Örneğin C++'ın standart kütüphanesi nasıl function overloading'den yoğun olarak faydalanıyorsa
operator overloading'den de yoğun olarak faydalanıyor.
O zaman önce operator overloading'in ne olduğundan bahsedelim.
Ve ne işe yaradığından bahsedelim.
Yani niye böyle bir araç var?
Bu araç ne?
Niye böyle bir araç var?
Ne işimize yarıyor?
Arkadaşlar, normalde C diline bakarsanız orada sınıflar yok ama orada da structure'lar var.
Örneğin struct, neç, C dilindeki bir yapı türü olsun ve struct, neç türünden bir değişkenimiz olsun.
Arkadaşlar, C dilinde bir yapı nesnesi sadece dört tane operatörün operanda olabilir.
Örneğin nokta operatörünün sol operanda olabilir, öyle değil mi?
Adres operatörünün operanda olabilir, size of operatörünün operanda olabilir ve adama operatörünün operanda olabilir.
Fakat C++ dilinde C'de olmayan şöyle bir araç seti var.
Bir sınıf nesnesi bir operatörün operanda olduğunda derleyici dilin kurallarından vazife çıkartarak operatörün operanda olmuş sınıf nesnesi ifadesini bir fonksiyon çağrısına dönüştürüyor.
Yani ortada doğrudan fonksiyon çağrı operatörü yok fakat kodun anlamı derleyicinin bir fonksiyona çağrı yapması.
İşte sınıf nesnesi bir operatörün operanda olduğunda derleyicinin bir fonksiyona, programcı tarafından yazılmış bir fonksiyona çağrı yapması mekanizmasına genel olarak operatör overloading diyoruz.
Burada söz konusu olan çağrılan fonksiyonla da operatör fonksiyonu diyoruz.
Bunlar özel nitelikte birazdan uzun uzun kurallarını öğreneceğimiz fonksiyonlar.
O zaman bir başka terim de operator functions.
Operator functions nasıl fonksiyonlar?
İşte bir sınıf nesnesi bir operatörün operanda olduğunda derleyicinin ifadeyi fonksiyon çağrısına dönüştürdüğü orada çağrılan fonksiyona operatör fonksiyonunu diyoruz.
Aslında biz bunun bir örneğini gördük.
Evet özel bir örnek bir special member function hatta iki special member function arkadaşlar bravo Yusuf.
Copy assignment ve move assignment aslında onlar da operatör fonksiyonları.
Hatta modern C++'dan önce move assignment, copy assignment denmiyordu.
Assignment operator function deniyordu.
Evet şimdi mesela A artı B böyle bir ifade düşünün.
A ve B bir sınıf türünden nesneler olsun.
Eğer bu durumda bildirilmiş ya da tanımlanmış bir fonksiyon varsa dilin kurallarına göre çağrılabilecek.
Derleyici A artı B ifadesini bir operatör fonksiyonuna yapılan çağrı ifadesine dönüştürüyor.
Bu çok önemli.
Necati burada çağrılan fonksiyonlar global fonksiyon mu yoksa sınıfın üye fonksiyonu mu?
İşte biraz da mekanizmayı daha karmaşık hale getiren her ikisi de olabilir.
Yani bir operatör fonksiyonu bir free function da olabilir.
Yani derleyici bu ifadeyi bir free function'a bir global function'a yapılan çağrıya dönüştürebilir.
Ya da bir non-static member function'a yapılan çağrıya dönüştürebilir.
Ya bir free function olacak ya da non-static member function olacak.
Şimdiden aslında bir kurala da gönderme yapmış olduk.
Static member function olamaz operatör fonksiyonları.
Peki operatör overloading'in ne olduğunu anladık.
O zaman bir soru daha soralım.
Bu runtime'a yönelik bir mekanizma mı?
Compile time'a yönelik bir mekanizma mı?
Cevap tabii ki Bravok'a ve pompile time'a yönelik bir mekanizma.
Çünkü derleyici hangi fonksiyonun çağrıldığını yine derleme zamanında anlıyor.
Yine eğer öyle bir ifade karşılığı dilin kurallarına göre çağrılabilecek bir fonksiyon yok ise durumu syntax hatası olarak nitelendiriyor.
Operatör overloading'in ne olduğunu konuşmuş olduk.
Peki ne işe yarıyor?
Arkadaşlar aslında son derece basit.
Bakınız operatörlerin primitif türleri için örneğin tam sayı türleri, gerçek sayı türleri, pointer türleri gibi verdiği doğal bir çağrışım var.
Yani örneğin ben arkadaşlar i1 artı i2 gibi bir ifade yazdığımda siz hemen bunlar intörden değişkenler olsun bunların toplanmasının kastedildiğini yani burada bir toplama işlemi yapıldığını koda bakarak görüyorsunuz.
Tam sayılar toplanır. Gerçek sayılar da toplanır.
Bakın iki gerçek sayının toplanmasında da biz aynı ortak arayüzü kullanıyoruz değil mi?
Ama şimdi örneğin kompleks sayıları temsil eden kompleks isimli bir sınıf olsun.
Kompleks sayılar toplanamaz mı?
Toplanabilir.
O zaman iki tane kompleks sayıyı örneğin toplama operatörüyle bu şekilde toplamak aslında bu iş bir fonksiyon tarafından yapılıyor olsa da daha yüksek bir soyutlama sağlıyor.
Daha yüksek bir ifade gücüne karşılık geriyor.
Arkadaşlar düşünsenize özellikle bu sadece tabii ki matematikle ilgili sınıflar değil ama matematikle ilgili sınıflarda bunun özellikle ne kadar fazla fayda sağlayacağını düşünebiliyor musunuz?
Mesela ismini yazdığım M harfiyle başlayan ben de tam o örneği verecektim Fatih.
Bütün değişkenlerin matris olduğunu düşünün.
Siz aslında diyelim ki şöyle bir kod yazdınız.
Burada iki tane çarpma operatörü bir tane toplama operatörü var.
Fakat derleyici bu kodu aslında şu çarpma işlemini yapacak bir fonksiyona çağrı.
Bu çarpma işlemini yapacak bir fonksiyona çağrı.
Sonra da bu çarpma işlemlerinden elde edilen matrislerin toplanmasını sağlayacak bir fonksiyona yapılan çağrıya dönüştürüyor.
Şimdi eğer böyle bir araç olmasaydı örneğin örneğin biz bunu C dilinde matris bir yapıyla temsil edilseydi arkadaşlar ne kadar karmaşık bir görüntü algısal açıdan zorluk yaratacak bir görüntü olacağını tahmin ediyorsunuz değil mi?
Mesela gideceğim ben multiply isimli bir fonksiyona çağrı yapacağım.
Ona M1'i ve M2'yi argüman olarak göndereceğim.
Tabi burada muhtemelen bir de pointer semantiği kullanılacak.
Sonra M3 ve M4 için yine multiply fonksiyonunu çağıracağım arkadaşlar.
Ve M3 ve M4'ü argüman olarak göndereceğim.
Sonra belki add fonksiyonuna bunları argüman olarak göndereceğim.
Böyle bir yapım.
Tabi bazen de tek bir ifade şeklinde yazmamız da mümkün olmayabilir.
Ama şimdi operatör overloading mekanizmasıyla aslında arka planda yine derleyicinin ürettiği kod böyle bir kod olduğunu düşünün.
Ama derdimizi bu şekilde ifade ettiğimizi düşünün.
Operatörlerin primitif türler için yaptığı çağrışımdan başka problem domenindeki varlıkları temsil eden sınıflar içinde faydalanıyoruz.
İşte matrislerin çarpılması, toplanması.
Mesela toplamaya bir örnek.
En iyi örneklerden biri.
İki string toplanabilir mi?
Dinin sentaksından bahsetmiyorum.
Tabi ki mesela Fatih stringi ile Akgül stringini yani bu iki yazıyı toplarsam Fatih Akgül yazısını elde edeceğim.
O zaman mesela string sınıfı S1 artı S2 derdimizi S1'de S2'de string nesneleri olsa bu şekilde ifade etsek kötü mü?
Hatta bu mekanizma çoğu zaman function overloading mekanizmasıyla arkadaşlar birlikte kullanılacak.
Mesela şunu yazdığınızı düşünün.
name artı eşit arkadaşlar Akgül ismin sonuna Akgül yazısını ekliyorum.
Karşılaştırma işlemleri.
Mesela düşünün arkadaşlar C'de string işlemlerini yaparken bizim tipi karşılaştırma fonksiyonumuz string compares.
Ben Türkçe okuyorum strcmp if değil strcmp efendim s1 s2 bu iki yazı eşitse demek.
Ama şimdi s1 ve s2 standart kütüphanenin ya da bir 3. parti kütüphanenin sınıflarından biri olsun doğrudan şöyle yazdığınızı düşünün.
if s1 eşit eşit s2 ise çok daha yüksek bir soyutlama ve hızlı bir algılama oluşturuyor.
Arkadaşlar burada henüz erken olsa da ne yapmayalım sorularından birine de cevap verelim.
Arkadaşlar operatör overloading'den faydalanabilmeniz için bunun çok ilal edildiğini görüyorum yaptığım kod review'larda.
Kesinlikle kullanımın intüütif olması gerekiyor.
Ne demek?
Özellikle İngilizce sözcük kullandım.
Yani sezgisel olarak anlaşılacak arkadaşlar.
Bazen ben şimdi örnek görüyorum.
Mesela yani sevimli de ama kötü örnekler.
Bitmiş programcı mesela image isimli bir sınıf türünden nesneler var.
Image 1 efendim ne olsun pipe bitsel veya operatörü image 2.
Böyle bir şey yapmak mümkün mü?
Mümkün.
Ama iyi bir fikir mi?
İyi bir fikir değil.
Çünkü burada intüütif bir şekilde bir algı doğmuyor.
Yani ne yapıyor?
İki resim birbirinin birleştiriliyor mu?
Bir resim bir resimden faydalanarak diğerinde bir filtrasyon mu yapıyorum?
Çok saçma.
Dolayısıyla sınıflarınız için operatör overloading'den faydalanacaksınız.
Belki verilebilecek bir numaralı tavsiye kesinlikle kullanımın intüütif olması.
Burada amaç client kodları yazanların işini kolaylaştırmak.
Kendi işimizi kolaylaştırmak değil.
Yani bizim sınıfımız daha yüksek, bizim sınıfımız türünden nesneler daha yüksek bir soyutlamayla kullanılabilsin.
Arkadaşlar örneğin vektör ne sınıfı?
İleride ayrıntılı göreceğiz.
Dinamik dizi sınıfı.
Ama vektör sonuçta bir dizi değil.
Mesela ben vektör sınıfı türünden bir nesne tanımladığımda arkadaşlar
Vektör sınıfı türünden bir nesne tanımladığımda aslında o bir dinamik diziyi temsil ediyor.
Asla müsaade ederseniz şunu hemen bir düzeltmek istiyorum.
Daha sonra daha fazla vakit kaybedeceğim çünkü.
Şurada benim oluşturduğum snippetlar var.
Bunlar
Evet şimdi oldu.
Bana çok zaman kazandırıyor.
Şimdi bakın yeniden deneyelim.
Vektör başlık dosyası.
Main fonksiyonu.
Stud
Vektörün
Int açılımı türünden
İVEC.
100 tane elemanla başlasın.
Arkadaşlar bu kendisi bir dizi değil ki.
Ben mesela İVEC köşeli parantez 5 yazıp
dinamik dizideki 5 indisli elemana erişeyim.
Bu da operatör overloading'in bir örneği değil mi?
Birçok sınıf operatör overloading mekanizmasını kullanıyor.
Mesela burada arkadaşlar
subscript operatörü overload edilmiş durumda.
Ya da smart pointer sınıflarını düşünün.
Smart pointer
Aslında kendisi pointer olmayan
ama pointer like
bir interfejse sahip
yani nesneleri pointermış gibi kullanılabilen sınıflara
popüler olarak pointer like sınıflar deniyor.
Eğer böyle sınıfların amacı
dinamik ömürlü nesnelerin
ya da kaynakların
hayatını, yaşam döngüsünü kontrol etmekse
böyle sınıflara
smart pointer sınıfları deniyor.
Mesela standart kütüphanenin
arkadaşlar
Unique PTR
sınıfını düşünün.
kod anlamaya çalışmayın.
Unique PTR
int
efendim
U-P-T-R
E şimdi
bu bir sınıf nesnesi
C'deki bir yapı nesnesi gibi düşünün.
Peki bu sınıf nesnesi
D-referencing operatörünün normalde operanda olabilir mi?
Hayır.
Ama bakın
madem ben bunu pointermış gibi kullanacağım
client kodların
aslında bu bir sınıf nesnesi olmasına rağmen
bunu pointermış gibi kullanabilmeleri
D-referencing operatörünün
operandı yapmalarıyla
kolay hale gelecek.
isimlendirilmiş bir fonksiyona
çağrı yapmaktan
çok daha yüksek algı oluşturuyor.
Örneğin yıldız U-B-T-R
eşittir 13.
Aslında ben böyle yazıyorum
ama derleyici
bunu
bir fonksiyona yapılan
çağrıya dönüştürüyor.
Barış Doğat.
Peki
şimdi o zaman
operatör overloading'in
genel olarak ne olduğundan bahsettik.
Mekanizmanın kendisine
operator overloading diyorum.
çağrılan fonksiyonlara
operator functions
diyeceğim
ve onları da
iki kategoriye ayıracağım.
Arkadaşlar
free function olan
operator function'lar
global operator functions
bir de
sınıfın non-statik
üye fonksiyonu olan
operator function'lar
onlar da
member operator function.
Şimdi
aşağı yukarı şöyle
bir en az
45 dakika
önce
operator overloading'in
makro düzeyde
kurallarını öğreneceğiz.
Yani işin
alfabesini öğreneceğiz.
Genel kurallar
operator overloading'le ilgili.
Burada
şöyle
10 civarında
temel
kuraldan
bahsedeceğim.
Bu kuralların
hiçbir şekilde
unutulmaması
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar.
sadece
unutsak da
syntax hatası
olacağını
göreceksiniz.
Arkadaşlar
o zaman
bir numaralı
kuraldan bahsedelim.
Operatör overloading'den
bahsedebilmem için
operatörün
operanda
olan
ifadelerden
en az
birinin
bir sınıf
türünden
ya da bir
enumeration
türünden
olması gerekiyor.
Yani
örneğin
şöyle bir şey
mümkün mü?
Mintür'den
iki tane
değişkenim var.
Arkadaşlar
şöyle bir
araç
seti var mı?
Ben örneğin
i1
artı
i2
yazıyorum.
Fakat
derleyici
normal
toplama
işlemi
yapacak
kodu
üretmek
yerine
bunu bir
fonksiyona
yapılan
çağrıya
dönüştürüyor.
Böyle
bir şey
mümkün mü?
kesinlikle
hayır.
O yüzden
eğer
bu
mekanizmadan
bahsedebilmemiz
söz konusuysa
binary
operatör
söz konusu
olduğunda
onun
operandlarından
en az
birinin
arkadaşlar
unary
operatörler
söz konusu
olduğu zaman
da operandın
ne olması
gerekiyor?
Bir
sınıf
türünden
ya da bir
enumeration
türden
olması
gerekiyor.
Anlaşıldı
değil mi?
eğer
operatörün
operant ya da
operantları
primitif
türlerdense
yani
int double
gibi türlerden
ya da
pointerlarsa
böyle bir
mekanizma
söz konusu
değil.
Bu birinci
kural
arkadaşlar.
Ben çok çok kısa
notlar
hatırlatmayan
mükemmel
tanım yapmayacağım
arkadaşlar
operantlardan
en az
biri
bir sınıf
numaralandırmayı
da katan
türünden
olacak.
Numaralandırma
biraz özel
bir durum
enumeration
olmalı.
Anlamadığımız
herhangi bir madde
olduğunda
tekrar etmemi
isteyin.
Bu bir.
İkincisi
arkadaşlar
bu mekanizmadan
bahsedebilmemiz
için
overload
edilecek
operatörün
yani onun için
fonksiyon
yazacağımız
operatörün
C++
dilinin
operatör
kümesinde
olması
gerekiyor.
Mesela şöyle bir şey
yapabilir miyim?
A1
add
A2
A1 ve
sınıf türünden
nesneler
olsun
ama ben
add
karakterini
bir token
olarak kullanıp
sanki bir
operatörmüş
gibi
böyle bir ifade
yazayım
derleyici de
bunu
bir fonksiyona
yapılan
çağrıya
dönüştürsün.
Cevap
hayır.
O zaman
bizzat biraz
bizim
Türkçemizde
halk tipi
ifade edersek
ben böyle
diyorum
olmayan
operatörün
yüklemesi
olmaz.
Olmayan bir
operatör
overload
edilemez.
Olmayan bir
operatöre
zaten
operatör
demememiz
gerekiyor.
Arkadaşlar
evet
ancak
C++
dilinin
operatör
kümesinde
setinde
olan
operatörler
overload
edilebilir.
devam.
Arkadaşlar
bu
amaçla
tanımlanacak
ya da
bildirilecek
fonksiyonları
keyfi
şekilde
isimlendiremiyorsunuz.
isim
şöyle
olmak zorunda
operatör
keyword'ü
ve
operatör
keyword'ünü
izleyen
hangi
operatörü
overload
ediyorsa
yani
sınıf
nesnesi
hangi
operatörün
operanda
olduğunda
o fonksiyon
çağrılacak
ise
bu
operatörün
token'ı.
Yani
toplama
operatörünü
overload
edecek
fonksiyonun
ismi
operator
plus.
Efendim
subscript
operatörünü
overload
edecek
fonksiyonun
ismi
operator
subscript
çarpma
operatörünü
overload
edecek
fonksiyonun
ismi
operator
multiply
olacak.
Anlaşıldı
mı?
Ya
başka bir
şekilde
isimlendirme
kesinlikle
mümkün
değil.
O yüzden
zaten
neden
atama
operatör
fonksiyonunu
diyoruz.
E çünkü
atama
operatörünü
overload
ediyor.
Evet bir
special
member
function
orada da
bahsetmiştim
special
member
function'lardan
move
assignment ve
copy
assignment
anlatırken
operatör
assignment
olması
kural
gereği.
Anlaşıldı
değil mi?
Peki
devam ediyoruz
o zaman.
Anlaşılmadık
bir durum
varsa
bunlar önemli
olduğu için
tekrar
etmemi
isteyin.
arkadaşlar
dilin
bütün
operatörleri
overload
edilemiyor.
Yani
bazı
operatörler
için
overloading
mekanizması
yasaklanmış,
kısıtlanmış.
Mesela
tahmin edebilir
misiniz?
Bilenler
değil de
tahmin edenler
söylesin.
Hangi
operatörlerin
overloadingi
yok?
Yani
sınıf
nesnesi
şu operatörün
operanda olsun
bir fonksiyon
çağrılsın.
ama
hangileri
için
yasaklanmış?
Hadi
bir tanesini
ben söyleyerek
başlayayım
siz de
tahmin edin.
Size
of
operatörü
arkadaşlar.
Mehmet Can
tahmininiz
doğru.
Başka?
Hayır.
Kalan
operatörü
overload
edilebiliyor.
Evet.
Referans
derken
referans
bir operatör
değil.
Nokta
operatörü.
Koşul
operatörü
Turner
Operator
Member
Selection
dot
Bravo
Yusuf
Emir Can
Scope
Resolution
Operatörü
Nokta
virgül
operatörü
overload
edilebiliyor
Oğuzhan.
Şimdi
yalnız
bu noktada
ben de
nokta
operatörü
derken
bu noktada
bir şey
önemli
belirteyim.
Bakın
syntactically
yani
syntax
açısından
overload
edilebilmesi
başka
ama
çok
nadiren
böyle bir
örnekle
karşılaşacak
olmanız
başka.
Mesela
comma
operator
overload
edilebiliyor
mu?
Evet.
Ama
comma
operatörünün
overload
edildiğini
görecek
misiniz?
Büyük
ihtimalle
hayır.
Yani çok
nadir
karşınıza
çıkar.
Ama
overload
edilmesinde
herhangi bir
şekilde
bir
engel
yok.
o zaman
size of
operatörü
nokta
törnery
operatör
arkadaşlar
şuna yazdım
member selection
da
scope resolution
operatörü
ya da daha sonra
öğreneceğimiz
örneğin
type id
operatörü
ve
burada
bir operatör
daha var
genelde
atlanıyor.
Arkadaşlar
bu operatörde
nokta yıldız
diyelim şimdilik
bu operatörde
overload
edilemiyor.
Ben böyle
dediğimde
C'den gelen
arkadaşlar
patlı olarak
diyecekler ki
böyle bir
operatörde mi
var?
Evet var
arkadaşlar.
C'de yok
ama C++'da
arkadaşlar
böyle bir
operatör
var.
Evet
bu operatörde
ileride
derslerimizin
bir
konusu
olacak.
Arkadaşlar
bu operatör
member
data
memberlar
için
ya da
member
functionlar
için
bir
bağlayıcı
operatör.
İki tane
operatör var
ileride
göreceğiz.
Biri
nokta yıldız
diğeri
ok yıldız.
İkisi
birbiriyle
aynı
bağlamda
kullanılan
operatörler.
Bunları
ileride
göreceğiz.
Evet.
Peki
o zaman
şimdilik
böyle
bırakalım.
Her
operatörünün
yüklemesi
olmaz.
Size
of
nokta
törneri
scope
resolution
type
id
gibi.
Devam
ediyoruz.
Operatör
fonksiyonlarının
bazıları
içinde
şöyle bir
kısıtlama
var.
Hani
iki
ayrı
şekilde
overload
edilebiliyordu
ya.
Bir
free
function
olarak
global
function
olarak
iki
arkadaşlar
sınıfın
üye
fonksiyonu
olarak.
Mesela
toplama
operatörü
addition
operator
yine
M1
ve M2
matriz
nesneleri
olsun.
Matriz
sınıfını
kim tasarladıysa
onun
verdiği
kararla
mesela
burada
operator
overloading
bir free
function'la
yapılmış
olabilir.
Benim
kişisel
olarak
tercihim
bu
olurdu.
Ama
pekala
bir
member
function'la
da yapılmış
olabilir.
Yani
burada
çağrılan
örneğin
global
bir
fonksiyonu
olabilir
ya da
matriz
sınıfının
büyüye
fonksiyonu
olabilir.
Ama
öyle
operatörler
var ki
free
function
olarak
overload
edilmesi
dil
tarafından
yasaklanmış.
Yani
member
function olmak
zorunda
free
function
olamıyor.
Bazı
operatörler
içinde
bu
kısıtlama
var.
Mesela
fonksiyon çağrı
operatörü
function
collaborator
free
function
olamıyor
arkadaşlar.
Ya da
subscript
operatörü
free
function
olamıyor
arkadaşlar.
Ya da
member
selection
arrow
operatörü
free
function
olamıyor.
Atama
operatörü
free
function
olarak
overload
edilemiyor.
Tür
dönüştürme
operatörleri
type
cast
operator
function
free
olamıyor.
O zaman
burada
tekrar edelim mi?
İki farklı
kısıtlama var.
Biri
yüklenemeyen
overload
edilemeyen
operatörler
var.
Diğer bir
kısıtlamada
overload
edilebiliyor
ama
free
function
olamıyor.
Tabi
bu kuralları
unutsanıza
mesela
free
function
olarak
overload
etme
girişinde
bulunduğunuzda
syntax
atası
alacaksınız.
Yani
unutmanız
zaten
bir kere
unutursunuz
ilk kere
üçüncü
de
terleyici
size
hatırlatır
ondan sonra
unutmazsınız.
Anlaştık mı?
Bir başka
önemli
madde
tüm
operatör
fonksiyonları
istisnasız
without
any
exception
arkadaşlar
isimleriyle
de
çağrılabilir.
Yani
biz
tipik olarak
operatör
fonksiyonlarını
notasyonuyla
çağırıyoruz.
Operatör
notasyonuyla
çağırıyoruz
derken
kastedilen ne?
sınıf
nesnesini
ya da
nesnelerini
operatörün
operanda
yapıyoruz.
Derleyici
onu
örtülü
şekilde
operatör
fonksiyonuna
yapılan
çağrıya
dönüştürüyor.
Ama
diğer
fonksiyonlar
gibi
isimleriyle
de
çağrılabilir.
Aslında
ben bunun
örneğini
vermiştim.
Bakınız
class
my
m1
m2
eşit
Bu da bir
operatör
overloading
mekanizması.
Evet bir
special
member
fonksiyon
ama
tüm
operatör
fonksiyonları
için
isimleriyle
de
çağrıyı
yapmak
mümkün.
Bu
sınıfın
üye
fonksiyonu
değil mi?
Çağrılacak
fonksiyon.
O zaman
sınıfın
üye
fonksiyonunun
ismi
fu
olsaydı
bu
fonksiyonunu
böyle
çağıracaktık.
Fakat
buradaki
fonksiyonun
ismi
operator
assignment.
O zaman
m2'yi de
argüman
olarak
gönderiyorum.
Yani
bu
şekilde
yazsam da
aynı
fonksiyona
çağrı
yapmış
oluyorum.
aklınıza
şöyle
bir
soru
gelebilir.
Aklınıza
şöyle
bir
soru
gelebilir.
Ya
zaten
bu
mekanizmanın
amacı
baştan
beri
söylemiyor
musun?
Daha
yüksek
düzeyde
bir
soyutlama,
algı
yaratmak,
client
kodu
yazan
programcının
işini
kolaylaştırmak.
neden böyle
çağırayım ki?
Ama şunu da söyleyeyim.
Öyle durumlar var ki
şu anda
değinmeyeceğim ama
karşımıza çıkacak
kurs süresince
gerçekten
operatör
notasyonuyla
değil
ya
mecburiyetten
ismiyle
çağırıyor olacağız
ya da
ismiyle
çağırmanın
o bağlamda
her yerde değil ama
birkaç bağlamda
daha iyi
belki
kabul edilebileceği
senaryolarda
karşılaşacağız.
Ama biz şimdi
genel maddelerimize
geri döndük
olursak
tüm
operatör
fonksiyonları
isimleriyle
de
çağrılabilir.
Anlaşamadığımız
herhangi bir
madde var mı?
Size
soyut gelen
henüz
bazı
söylediğim
kurallar
olabilir
ama
tabii ki
ayrıntıya
gireceğiz
ilerleyen
saatlerde.
Biri
hariç
yani
bir
operatör
fonksiyonu
hariç
operatör
fonksiyonları
yani
operatör
overloading
mekanizmasında
kullanılan
fonksiyonlar
default
argument
alamazlar.
normalde
gerek
free
fonksiyonlar
global
gerekse
sınıfların
üye fonksiyonları
default
argument
alabilirler.
Değil mi?
Kursun
çok
başlarında
ilk birkaç
ders içinde
default
argument
ne demek
onu
öğrenmiştik.
Fakat bu
operatör
fonksiyonları
için
biri hariç
bu mekanizma
yasaklanmış.
Yani
operatör fonksiyonlarına
default argument
veremezsiniz.
Hemen
tahmin edebilir
misiniz acaba?
Hangi
operatör fonksiyonu
default
argument
alabilir?
function
call
operator
fonksiyon
çağrı
operatörü
peki
devam
tüm
operatör fonksiyonları
isimleri
diye çağrılabilir.
Bir
operatör fonksiyonu
hariç
operatör fonksiyonları
default argument
alamazlar.
Şimdi en önemli
maddelerden biri
ama biraz kafanızı
karıştırabilecek.
O yüzden
dikkatli
izlemenizi
istiyorum.
arkadaşlar
evet
bakınız
operatör
overloading
mekanizmasında
operatörlerin
İngilizce bir
terim kullanacağım
doğrudan
Türkçe karşılığını
uyduramıyorum
eritisi
değiştirilemez.
Ne demek bu?
Burada
operatörün
eritisi
derken
kast edilen
operatörün
unary
ya da
binary
olması
biraz burada
sabırlı
davranmanızı
sabırlı olmanızı
isteyeceğim.
5-10 dakika
bir 5-10 dakika konuşmam
gerekecek.
Ondan sonra sorularınızı
sorabilirsiniz.
O zaman bir kez daha
tekrar edelim.
Operatörlerin
eritisi
değiştirilemez.
Yani eriti ne demekmiş?
Operatörün
unary
ya da
binary olması.
mesela
toplama
operatörü
ya da çarpma
binary
bir operatör.
O zaman
binary
operatör
olduğuna
bağlı
şekilde
overload
edilecek.
Açıklayacağım.
Lojik
değil
operatörü.
Unary
bir operatör.
O zaman
unary
olarak
overload
edilecek.
Yani
binary
operatörse
operatör
olduğu
kuralına
göre
unary
ise
operatör
olduğu
kuralına
göre.
Bu ne
demek?
O yüzden
uyardım.
Biraz konuşmam
gerekiyor.
Çok soyut
kalacak.
Şimdi
somutlaştıralım.
Arkadaşlar
çok dikkatli
izleyin.
Diyelim ki
x
çarpı
y
gibi bir
ifadede
x ve
y
yine
bizim
meşhur
matrix
sınıfımız
türünden
nesneler
olsun.
Şimdi
söyleyin
bakalım
çarpma
operatörü
binary
bir
operatör mü?
Cevap
evet.
O zaman
binary
operatörü
olarak
overload
edecek.
Bu şu
demek.
Eğer
herkes
çok
dikkatli
izlesin.
Bu
overloading
bir
free
functionla
yapılıyorsa
bu durumda
çarpma
operatörünün
sol operandı
da
sağ
operandı
da
o
fonksiyonun
parametrelerine
argüman
olarak
gönderiliyor.
yani
sizin
x çarpı
y gibi
bir ifade
yazmanız
burada
hatta
şöyle
diyelim
global
function
ise
herkes çok
dikkatli
izliyor.
x çarpı
y ifadesini
denleyici
neye
dönüştürecek?
Kave
operator
multiply
x
virgül
y
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz?
Evet.
ya da
isterseniz
çıkartma
operatöründen
çarpma
hatta
karşılaştırma
operatöründen
örnek verebiliriz.
Mesela
x büyüktür
y
operatör
büyüktür
fonksiyonla
x ve y
argüman
olarak gönderiyoruz.
Şimdi
söyler misiniz
bu durumda
büyüktür
operatörünü
overload
etmekte
kullandığımız
global
fonksiyonun
kaç tane
parametre
değişkeni
olmalı?
Bu bir soru.
Cevap
iki.
Bu ne
demek
Mehmetcan?
Üç tane
parametresi
olursa
sentaks
hatası
olur.
Bir tane
parametresi
olursa
sentaks
hatası
olur.
İlla
iki tane
parametresi
olacak.
İsterseniz
deneyelim.
Burayı
anlamamız
önemli.
Mesela
class
matrix
sözde
bizim
matriz
sınıfımız.
Public
şimdi
global
fonksiyon
bildiriyorum.
Operatör
örneğin
küçüktür.
Geri
dönüş
değeri
boğul
olsun.
Parametrelerinden
biri
const
matrix
bir tane
parametresi
olsun.
Const
matrix
rev.
Veri Bayer
Yusuf
Furkan
sentaks
hatası
var mı?
Cevap
kesinlikle
çünkü
küçüktür
operatör
binary
bu da
global
function
dolayısıyla
derleyici
durumu
sentaks
hatası
olarak
değerlendirecek.
Bakın
derleyicinin
verdiği
sentaks
hatası
mesajını
birlikte
okuyalım.
Error
derleyicinin
error
kodu
binary
operator
less
has
too
few
parameters
yani
gereğinde
nas
parametresi
var diyor.
Oysa
bir
parametre
daha
koysaydım
arkadaşlar
derlediğim
zaman
sentaks
hatası
oluşmayacaktı.
Üçüncü
bir
parametre
koysam
yine
sentaks
hatası
olduğunu
arkadaşlar
göreceksiniz.
Burayı
herkes
anladı mı?
Evet.
O zaman
buraya
geri dönelim.
Eğer
binary
bir
operatörü
global
function
olarak
overload
ediyorsak
function
overloading
de
kullanmak
istediğimiz
fonksiyon
bir
global
function
bir
free
functions
iki
tane
parametresi
olacak.
Böylece
derleyici
operatörün
sol
operandanı
fonksiyonun
birinci
parametresine
sağ
operandanı
fonksiyonun
ikinci
parametresine
geçecek
bir kod
üretecek.
Fakat
member
function
ise
buraya
dikkat.
Eğer
binary
operatörü
overload
edecek
fonksiyon
sınıfın
üye
fonksiyonuysa
burada
değişmez
ve çok
önemli bir
kural
var.
O
üye
fonksiyon
binary
operatörün
sol
operandı
için
çağrılıyor.
Yani
this
pointerı
lan
statik
üye
fonksiyon
olduğuna
göre
this
pointerı
var
değil mi?
This
pointerı
arkadaşlar
sol
operant
olan
nesnenin
adresi.
Şimdi
member
function
ise
tekrar
yazalım
x
y
o zaman
derleyici
bunu
nasıl bir
fonksiyon
çağrısına
dönüştürecek?
Aslında
x
nokta
operator
arkadaşlar
greater
y
burayı anladık mı?
Her zaman
sol operant olan nesne için çağrılacak.
Şimdi o zaman söyler misiniz?
Eğer bu
overloading
matriz
sınıfının
belki matriz
sınıfı için
küçüktür
büyüktür
de çok
anlamlı
değil herhangi bir
sınıf için olsun
arkadaşlar
örneğin string
sınıfı için
üye
operatör
fonksiyonu
olarak yazılırsa
kaç tane
parametresi
olması lazım?
Cevap
bir
bravo
çünkü
zaten
nesnelerden
biri
nokta
operatörünün
solundaki
nesne
arkadaşlar
bu arada bir yanlış
olmasın
Yusuf şüphesi
onu kastetmiyor
ama
tek parametre
yeter derken
iki parametre olsa
zaten
syntax hatası
olacak.
Anlaşıldı değil mi?
Tek parametre
yeter derken
tek parametre
olmak zorunda.
Hadi buna da örnek
verelim.
Mesela
class
string
arkadaşlar
bool
operatör
less
akıl sınıfın
üye fonksiyonu
const
string
rev
const
bildiğimiz
diğer fonksiyonlar
gibi
const member
function
olabilir.
Derliyorum
Yusuf
bir
syntax hatası
yok.
Mesela
parametre
değişkeni
olmasaydı
syntax
hatası
olacaktı.
Ama
sadece
tek
parametre
değişkeni
olmamız
durumunda
değil.
ikinci bir
parametre
değişkeni
olsaydı
yine
syntax
hatası
olacaktı.
Burayı
anladık mı?
Çok önemli.
O zaman
kaldığımız
yerden
şimdi
global fonksiyonu
olması durumunda
iki tane
parametre
değişkeni
olacak.
Vya fonksiyonu
olması durumunda
bir tane
parametre
değişkeni
olacak.
Bunun
nedenini
konuştuk.
Ama
şimdi
bir de
unary
function'lara
operator'lara
bakalım.
Unary
operators
Arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
ptr
bir sınıf
nesnesi
ve
yani bildiğimiz
pointer değil
raw pointer
değil
pointer gibi
davranacak bir
sınıf nesnesi
ve
logic değil
operatörünün
operandı
olmuş.
şimdi
global
member
function
ise
global
function
ise
derleyici
bu
operatör
ifadesini
global
operatör
değil
fonksiyonuna
çağrıya
dönüştürecek
doğal
olarak
operatörün
operanda
olan sınıf
nesnesinde
bu
fonksiyona
yapılan
çağrıda
argüman
olarak
kullanılacak.
bu durumda
artık soruyu
sormak bile
gereksiz hale
gelmiş olabilir.
Operatör
değil
fonksiyonu
global
olduğunda
kaç tane
parametresi
olmalı?
Arkadaşlar
cevap
bir tane
parametresi
olmalı.
Bravo.
Yani
mesela
yine
class
smart
ptr
sözde
bakın
bool
operatör
değil
const
smart
ptr
ref
derleyici
buna
herhangi bir
cekli bir
sentaks
hatası
vermedi
alham
ama
fonksiyonun
a
parametre
değişkeni
olmasaydı
b
ikinci bir
parametre
değişkeni
olsaydı
derleyici
her iki
durumu da
sentaks
hatası
olarak
niteleyecekti.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Peki
üye fonksiyonu
olduğunda
tekrar buraya
geri dönelim.
O zaman
değil
ptr
gibi bir
ifade
işte
buradaki
ptr
az önce
ki kodda
smart
ptr
ismini
verdiğim
sınıf
türünden
bir nesne
olsun
ve bu
durumda
bu
üye fonksiyonu
olduğuna
göre ortada
başka bir
nesne
hangi
için
çağrılacak?
ptr
nesnesi
için.
O zaman
fonksiyonun
ismi
operatör
değil
olacak.
Kaç
tane
parametresi
olmalı?
Cevap
parametresiz.
Bravo
olsan
sıfır.
Şimdi
bakın
örneğin
sınıfın
hablik
fonksiyonu
operatör
değil.
has
ve
geri dönüş
değeri
diyelim
bu türden
olsun
derleyici
buna
bir
sentax
hatası
vermedi
ama
giderdi.
Smart
ptr
türünden
örneğin
bir
parametre
koşsam
hangi
türden
olursa
olsun
derleyici
durumu
sentax
hatası
olarak
değerlendirdi.
O zaman
bu
maddenin
artık
anlaşıldığını
kabul edebilir
miyim?
En başa
geri dönelim.
Nereden
başladık?
Operatörlerin
arraytisi
değiştirilemez
dedik.
Önce
arraytinin
tanımını
yaptık.
Ondan sonra
da
binary
operatörlerin
olarak
unary
operatörlerin
olarak
overload
edilmesinden
bahsettik.
Peki
soru
arkadaşlar
soruya
dikkat
operatör
artı
class
string
sentax
hatası
mı
değil mi?
Sentax
hatası
değil.
Herkesi
yanılttığım
hadi
bugün
bir sıfır
galibim.
ben seviyorum
böyle çoğunluğun
yanlış
cevap vereceğini
yanlış anlaşılmasını
yani hoşuma gidiyor
anlamında
demek ki önemli
bir kısmı
onlarda
anlayacaklar
şimdi.
Neden
sentax
hatası
değil?
Çünkü
bu
toplama
operatörünü
overload
etmiyor.
Arkadaşlar
dört tane
token'a
dikkat
bakın
artı
hem
toplama
operatörü
addition
hem de
sign
operatörü
işaret
örneğin
x artı
y'deki
artı
toplama
operatörü
addition
ama
artı
x ifadesindeki
bu operatöre
ne diyoruz?
Bu da bir operatör
sign
operator
aynı şekilde
x eksi
y
bu
subtraction
yani
çıkartma
Türkçesiyle
operatörü
ama
eksi
x
bu da
sign
operator
evet
söyleyin
bakalım
arkadaşlar
x
ampersan
y
bu hangi
operatör?
Necdo
dalga mı
geçiyorsun
bizde?
tabii ki
bitwise
end
operatörü
ama
bu hangi
operatör?
Bu ise
address
operatörü
ve
son olarak
x
yıldız
y
bu
multiplication
operatörü
ama
yıldız
örneğin
p
buradaki
operatörün
İngilizce'deki
ismi
dereferencing
operatörü
dolayısıyla
tekrar
sorumuza
biraz sizin
yanıtmak için
sorduğumuz
soruya
geri dönecek
olursak
örneğin
tabii
string
sanıfı için
böyle bir
operatörü
ihtiyaç duyulmayacağı
açık
biraz daha
mantıklı
getirmek için
any class
anlamında
herhangi bir
sınıf
olsun
şimdi
arkadaşlar
my class
operatör
plus
hangi
operatörü
overload
etmiş olduk
işaret
operatörünü
overload
etmiş oluyoruz
ama
bakın
bir
operatör
artı
daha
operatör
artı
my class
şimdi
buradaki
sign
operator
ama
alttaki
direct
ben
derken
kazatmış
oluyorum
di referenzi
anlaşıldı
değil mi
evet
arkadaşlar
devam edelim
maddelerimize
operatör
overloading
mekanizmasında
doğal olarak
bunu belki
yazmaya bile
gerek yok
function overloading
de kullanılabilir
bu ne demek
mesela
diyelim ki
bizim
begin
diye bir sınıfımız
olsun
ben şöyle bir şey
yazabilir miyim
operatör
artı
int
const
begin
operatör
artı
long
operatör
artı
long
gibi
gördüğünüz gibi
hiçbir
sentaks
hatası
yok
son derece
doğal
bir sınıfın
birden fazla
operatör
artı
fonksiyonu
olabilir
ya da
birden fazla
operatör
falanca
fonksiyonu
olabilir
yine aynı
kural
geçerli
imzaları
farklı
olmak üzere
burada da
function overloading
den
faydalanılabilir
arkadaşlar
bakınız
function overloading
aslında
en tipik örneği
bu neye kadar
her derste
kullandık
neredeyse
operatör
lab
çiftin
overload edilmesi
ya da
operatör
right
çiftin
int
x
e
shift
enterom
burayı
belki
daha önce
bu kadar
net
algılamamış
olabilirsiniz
ama
bakınız
iostream
başlık
dosyasını
dahil
edelim
şimdilik
bir
using
namespace
direktifi
kullanalım
c
alt
x
ve
tör ayarlarını
değiştirmem
gerekiyor
evet
c
alt
divide
arkadaşlar
nasıl oluyor
da
burada
operatör
lab çifti
normalde
bu bitsel
sola
kaydırma
operatörü
kullanabiliyorum
e bu da
operatör
overloading
mekanizması
yani
aslında
arkadaşlar
bakın
böyle yazmak
see out
nokta
operatör
lab çift
fonksiyonuna
neyi
argüman
olarak
göndermek
x'i
argüman
olarak
göndermek
arkadaşlar
hatta
biraz daha
karmaşık
ama
tekrar
operatör
lab çift
bu sefer
global
operatör
lab çift
fonksiyonuna
çağrı
yapıp
bu karakteri
argüman
olarak göndermek
yine aynı
şekilde
aslında
deval'i
yazdıran
bu kodda
arkadaşlar
böyle
evet
şimdi bu ikisini
siliyorum
derleyip
çalıştırıyorum
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
bu da bir
operatör
overloading
mekanizması
tabi ki
şimdiye kadar
bunun üstünde
durmadık
belki ilk
derste
sadece bir
gönderme
yaptım
arkadaşlar
ama burada
bu kodu yazmanın
bir nedeni daha var
bakın şimdi
bu da sınıfın
member
function'ı
bu da sınıfın
member
function'ı
ama
inti yazdıran
member
function
see out
bir global
sınıf
nesnesinin
ismi
bu sınıfın
o stream
yani
see out
o stream
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesne
biz
o stream
sınıfının
operator
left shift
fonksiyonuna
x'i argüman
olarak gönderdik
ama burada
deval'i argüman
olarak gönderdik
burada yine
function
overload
resolution'la
derleyici
int parametreli
fonksiyonun
çağrılması
gerektiğini
burada ise
double parametreli
fonksiyonun
çağrılması
gerektiğini
anladı
şimdi
ne kastettiğimi
anladınız
değil mi
operator
overloading
function
overloading'le
birlikte
kullanılabilir
yani bir sınıfın
aynı isimli
birden fazla
operator
fonksiyonu
olabilir
bu arada
olası bir
yanlış anlamaya da
mahal
vermemek için
öyle diyorlar ya
atom operatör
fonksiyonu
demek
arkadaşlar
illa
special member
function
olması
anlamına
gelmiyor
mesela
şöyle fonksiyonlar
olabilir mi
operator
atom
arkadaşlar
my
class
ref
int
parametreli
atom operatör
fonksiyonu
double
parametreli
atom operatör
fonksiyonu
takip edebiliyor muyuz
bu ne demek
my class
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesneye
bir int
atadığımızda
buradaki
fonksiyon
çağrılacak
ama bir
double atadığımızda
9.
satırda
bildirilen
fonksiyon
çağrılacak
my class
m
eşittir
burada
çağrılan
8.
satırdaki
fonksiyon
m
eşittir
efendim
double
türden
burada
çağrılan
9.
satırdaki
fonksiyon
anlaşıldı mı
bir maddeyi
en başta
söylemiştik
ama
isterseniz
bir de
tekrar edelim
hangi
madde
statik
üye fonksiyon
olamaz
operatör
fonksiyon
operatör fonksiyonları
statik
üye fonksiyon
olamaz
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
aşağı yukarı tamamladık
bir iki madde daha
ekleyebilirim
çok hızlı bir şekilde
üstünden geçelim mi
hatta şöyle
kapatalım
siz
benim söylediğim
cümleleri
kendi
ama bir tane daha
önemli
madde var
isterseniz o maddeyi
de tamamlayalım
ondan sonra bir
listeyi
baştan sona
hızlı bir şekilde
elden geçiren
en önemli
maddelerden birine
geldik şimdi
arkadaşlar
operatör overloading
mekanizmasında
operatörlerin
öncelik seviyesini
ve öncelik yönünü
değiştiremeyiz
bu en önemli
maddelerden biri
operatör
öncelik
seviyesi
ve
operatör
öncelik
yönü
değiştirilemez
bu ne demek
şimdi
burada biraz
arkadaşlar
yine sabırlı
olup
5-10 dakika
dinlemeniz
gerekecek
diyelim ki
class
begin
çok büyük
tam sayıları
temsil etmek için
oluşturulmuş
bir sınıf olsun
ve
benim
begin
sınıfı
türünden
B1
B2
B3
B4
gibi
nesnelerim
olsun
takip edebiliyor muyuz
mesela ben şöyle bir şey
yapsam
arkadaşlar
B1
efendim
çarpı
B2
artı
B3
çarpı
B4
arkadaşlar
efendim
bitsel ve
B5
lütfen işlemlerin
bu sınıf için uygun olmadığını düşünmeyin
sadece
arkadaşlar
B6
takip edebiliyor muyuz
B6'da bir değişken olsun
hatta B6'yi şimdilik katmayalım
şöyle kalsın
çok da uzatmak istemiyorum
ve bunu da
bir değişkene
atayalım
şimdi tabii ki bu operatörler
overload edilmediği için
yardımcı program
syntax hatası işaretliyor
lütfen burayı
takip etmeye çalışın
dikkatli takip etmeye çalışın
bir nedenden dolayı
programcımız
yani
begin sınıfını tasarlayan
programcımız
buradaki
operatörlerin
hepsini
global operator
function olarak
overload etmiş olsun
yani hiçbiri
member function
değil
şimdi lütfen izleyin
arkadaşlar
aslında
C'nin
ve C++'ın
en azından
burada bir fark yok
operatör önceliği
yani operatörlerin
precedence
ya da
prioritesi
İngilizcesi ve
operatörün öncelik yönü
yani operatör
öncelik seviyesinin
İngilizcesi
associativity
açısından
baktığımızda
çarpma operatörü
daha yüksek
öncelikli değil mi
bunların arasından
evet
arkadaşlar
yani sanki burada
önerik parantezi
varmış gibi
takip edebiliyor muyuz
peki
toplama operatörü mü
daha yüksek
öncelikli
bitsel
V operatörü mü
cevap
tabii ki
toplama operatörü
o zaman yukarıdaki
ifade
bu anlamına geliyor
değil mi
çağrı
Oğuzhan
Fatih
yani normalde
bunlar int
olsaydı
zaten bu ifade
bu anlama
gelecekti
değil mi
şimdi
bu fonksiyonların
gerçekten
free function
olduğunu düşünelim
bakın bakalım
operatör
çarpma
geri dönüş
değeri
begin
diyelim ki
parametre
const
begin
ref
const
begin
ref
dikkat ederseniz
yardımcı araç
arkadaşlar
çarpmanın
demin altını
çizmişti
şimdi altını
çizmeyi bıraktı
çünkü artık
bu fonksiyona
çağrı yapılabilir
toplama operatörü
bu da
sıra dışı
şekilde
bitsel
V operatörü
olsun
niye bitsel
V operatörü
böyle kullanılsın
konumuz o değil
buraya kadar
takip edebildik mi
arkadaşlar
bakınız
kodu derlediğimde
herhangi bir şekilde
bir sentaks
hatası var mı
kaç tane
operatör varsa
o kadar fonksiyon
çağrılacak
arkadaşlar
hatta
şöyle yapalım
begin
bx
yani bunu
tanımlama yapmayalım
bunu da atama yapalım
tam 5 kez
fonksiyon
çağrılacak
değil mi
çarpma
operatör fonksiyonu
iki kere
çağrılacak
toplama operatörü
bir kez
çağrılacak
atama operatörü
bir kez
çağrılacak
peki
şimdi
sorunun
güzel kısmı
geliyor
ben bunu
biraz akıllı
iş olmazdı
ama
bu kodu
böyle yazmak
yerine
burada
ne kadar fonksiyon
varsa
çağrısı varsa
hepsini
isimleriyle
çağırıyor
olsaydım
nasıl bir kod
oluşurdu
işte
hem bize
operatör öncelik
seviyesi
yönüne ilişkin
az önce söylediğim
kuralı
anlatacak
hem de
operatör
overloading'in
bir yerde de
faydasını
göreceksiniz
bakın böyle
yazmak
varken
şimdi ne yazmak
zorunda kalacağım
operatör
çarpma
multiply fonksiyonunu
b1'i ve b2'yi
argüman olarak
gönderdim
aşağıya bakın
operatör önceliğine
yine
operatör
çarpma fonksiyonuna
b3'ü ve b4'ü
argüman olarak
gönderdim
buradan elde ettiğim
geri dönüş
değerlerini
yani
the return values
of the
function calls
kime argüman
olarak gönderdim
operatör
artıya
böylece
ifadenin bu kısmı
halledildi
ama
bitsel v operatörü
da binary
bir operatör
operatör
bitsel v
arkadaşlar
virgül
b5
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
ama işimiz bitmedi
bx
nokta
operatör
atama
arkadaşlar
ister inan
mayın
işte
19. satırdaki
kodun
aslında
20. satırdaki
kodla
anlamsal
açıdan
hiçbir farkı
yok
biri
fonksiyon
çağrılarının
operatör
notasyonuyla
yapılmış
olduğu durumu
gösteriyor
alttaki ise
isimleriyle
yapılmış
olması
anlaşıldı mı?
şimdi
operatör
önceliği ve
öncelik yönü
değiştirilemez
derken
neyi kastettiğimi
umarım
anlamışsınızdır
mesela
derleyici şöyle bir kod üretebilir miydi
arkadaşlar
sanki
operatör
efendim
bitsel v
toplama operatöründen
daha yüksek öncelikliymiş gibi
ya da çarpma operatöründen
bu ifadede
örneğin b4 ve b5'i
bitsel v işlemine
sokmak için
operatör
bitsel v
b4 ve b5 gibi
bir çağrı kodu
üretebilir miydi?
hayır
derleyiciden
derleyiciye
değişebilecek bir durum mu?
hayır
o zaman
ben burada
ne şekilde
gösterdiysem
yani madem
dilin kuralı
operatörlerin
operantlarına
ayrıştırılması
böyle
diyor
burada da
fonksiyonlar
bu şekilde çağrılmış
olmak zorunda
ama durunurum
ara vermeden
bir şey daha yapacağız
şimdi
2 dakika
tam 21.10'da
vermek istemiştim
hadi verelim
Oğuzhan
kırmayalım
Oğuzhan'ı
21.08
arkadaşlar
21.25'de
başlayacağız
17 dakika
ara veriyorum
21.25
şimdi aynı örnek
üstünde
şöyle bir değişiklik
yapalım
bu kez
çarpma
toplama
ve
bitsel v
bitwise end
operatörlerini
overload eden
fonksiyonlar
sınıfımızın
üye fonksiyonları
olsun
public
bu durumda
şüphesiz bu fonksiyonların
bir tane parametre değişkenleri olacak
ve birazdan
tartışmayı
açacağız
arkadaşlar
konstüya fonksiyon
olacaktır
yani
olmaları daha iyi
semantik
olarak
bakınız
main fonksiyonunu
yorum satırını
alayım
ve derleyim
buraya kadar
bir sentaks
hatası yok
arkadaşlar
yine
buradaki
ifade
bu şekilde
ele alınacak
o zaman
derleyici
nasıl
bir fonksiyon
çağrı zinciri
oluşturacak
bu kez
buradaki
çarpma
işleminin
yapılması için
B1'in
operatör
çarpma
fonksiyonunu
çağıracak
ve B2'ye
argüman olarak
gönderecek
B3'ün
operatör
çarpma
fonksiyonunu
çağıracak
ve B4'e
argüman olarak
gönderecek
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
ama şimdi
buradan elde edilen
değerle
değerin
toplanması
gerekiyor
ama
toplama da
sınıfın
üye fonksiyonu
buradan elde edilen
Bigging
nesnesinin
yani fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerini
oluşturan
Bigging nesnesinin
operatör
artı
fonksiyonunu
çağıracak
ve bu
ifadeyi
argüman olarak
gönderecek
yine
en son yapılan
fonksiyon çağrısından
elde edilen
geri dönüş
değeri mekanizması
ile elde edilen
Bigging nesnesinin
operatör
bitsel
B fonksiyonunu
çağıracak
ve ona da
B5'i
argüman olarak
gönderecek
yine
BX'in
operatör
atama fonksiyonunu
çağıracak
ve son fonksiyon
çağrısından
elde edilen
geri dönüş
değerini
argüman olarak
geçecek
şimdi durum
net olarak
anlaşıldı mı
evet
operatör öncelik
seviyesini
ve operatör
öncelik yönünü
yani
operatörlerin
priorities
ya da
presidensini
ve
associativitiesini
değiştirme
şansına
sahip
değiliz
bu şekilde
olmak zorunda
başka bir yol
mümkün
değil
buraya kadar
sorusu olan
var mı
der demez
atama yanlış oldu
evet
kopyala yapıştır
yaptığım için
ya da
otomatik tamamladı
teşekkür ederim
const begin
kullanmadığımız halde
neden hata
vermedi
soruyu
anlayamadım
arkadaşlar
niye hata
versin
vermesini
düşünüyorsunuz
hata
vermesini
gerektiren
bir
senaryo
yok
nerede
const begin
kullanmamız
gereksin
bir sınıfın
üye fonksiyonunun
const olması
o fonksiyonun
const bir nesneyle
çağrılması
gibi bir
zorunluluk
getirmiyor
şüphesiz
Fatih
evet
bir yeri
yanlış anlamış
olabilirsiniz
peki
şimdi
buraya kadar
gayet güzel
geldik
arkadaşlar
t ref ref
fonksiyonların
parametresini
diğer fonksiyonlar
gibi
istediğiniz gibi
yapabilirsiniz
yani
sentaks açısından
bir kısıtlama
yok
yani ben örneğin
bu fonksiyonun
parametresini
const begin
ref yerine
begin de
yapabilirdim
ya da
sağ taraf
referansı da
yapabilirdim
işime geliyorsa
hatta öyle bir
overloading de
yapabilirdim
anlaşıldı
değil mi
bu benim
seçimim
sentaks açısından
resul
herhangi bir şekilde
bir
kısıtlama yok
şimdi zaten
yavaş yavaş
oraya doğru
ilerleyeceğiz
arkadaşlar
mülakatlarda da
sorulan
şöyle bir
soru var
belki kötü bir
soru da değil
global
operatör
fonksiyonları
neden var
mesela mekanizmayı
biraz daha
basitleştirmek için
ve öğrenim
kolaylığı sağlamak
için
şöyle deselerdi
global operator
function diye
bir şey yok
sadece
member operator
function var
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
o zaman
neleri
yapamazdık
bakın
bu sorunun
cevabını
aslında
hemen
verebilirsiniz
arkadaşlar
mesela
toplama
çıkarma
çarpma
ya da
relational operators
comparison
bunlar
binary operatör
değil mi
mesela
x bir sınıf
nesnesi ise
örneğin
x'i
5'le
toplamak için
böyle bir ifade
yazabilirim
bu durumda
sınıfın
üye fonksiyonunun
çağrılmasında
bir engel yok
enderleyici
bunu
x'in
operator
plus
fonksiyonunu
çağıracak
ve sağ operanda
da
argüman olarak
gönderecek
ama
x artı 5
gibi bir işlemi
yapabilmem
tabi ki
nasıl bir
beklentiyi de
doğal hale
getiriyor
toplama
işleminde
değişme özelliği
olduğuna göre
x artı 5
yazabiliyorsam
doğal olarak
5 artı x de
yazabilmeliyim
ama şimdi
sol operand
bir sınıf
türünden
değil ki
int türünün
bir operatör
fonksiyonu
olamaz
ancak
böyle bir işlem
global operatör
fonksiyonuyla
yapılabilir
birinci açıklamayı
anladınız mı
eğer global
operatör fonksiyonu
olmasaydı
sol operandın
bir sınıf
türünden
olmaması
durumunda
örneğin
ekranda gördüğünüz
kodda olduğu gibi
primitif
bir türden
olması
durumunda
bunu
sınıfın
üye operatör
fonksiyonuna
çağrıya dönüştürme
imkanı
doğrudan
olmazdı
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar bir başka
neden de şu
mesela
çok dikkatli
izleyin
çok canlı
bir örnek
vereyim
diyelim ki
sizin
yine
matrix
isimli
sınıfınız var
hatta şuraya
yazalım
class
matrix
ve
sınıfa
türünden
nesneleri
çıkış akımlarına
output
streamlere
vermek için
ortak
arayüzü
koruma
adına
ki
birinci
amacımız
bu olmalı
operatör
left shift
fonksiyonunu
overload
etmek
istiyorsunuz
ama
şimdi
çıkış akımına
vermek için
arkadaşlar
bizim bir
neye ihtiyacımız var
bir stream
nesnesine
ihtiyacımız var
o zaman
binary bir
operatör olduğuna
göre
şöyle bir
görüntünün
olması
gerekiyor
matrix
sınıfı
türünden
m
arkadaşlar
c
out
left
shift
m
peki
bunun
üye operatör
fonksiyonu
olması için
ne olması
gerekir
hangi sınıfın
üye fonksiyonu
olması
gerekir
sol operant
olan
c
out nesnesinin
ilişkin olduğu
sınıfın
üye operatör
fonksiyonu
olması
gerekir
ama o sınıf
benim değil ki
o sınıfı
ben yazmadım ki
dolayısıyla
bunu
üye operatör
fonksiyonu
olarak yazmam
mümkün değil
ama halen
global
operatör
fonksiyonu
olarak
yazabilirim
değil mi
ki
çok
yakın zamanda
böyle fonksiyonları
yazacağız
böyle fonksiyonlara
popüler olarak
insörter
deniyor
bir streame
örneğin
bir sınıf
nesnesine
vermek için
insert etmek için
yani onu
streame
beslemek
onun değerini
formatlı olarak
yazdırmak için
peki ne
yapsaydık
bu mümkün
olurdu
global
bir operatör
fonksiyonu
yazsaydık
operatör
left
shift
birinci
operant
parametre
fonksiyonun
birinci parametri
c
out'ı
alacak
stud
o stream
rep
c
out nesnesinin
türü
bu tabi c
out olmak
zorunda da
değil
herhangi bir
stream nesnesi
bizim örneğimizde
c out
nesnesi olduğu için
böyle söyledim
ikinci parametre de
matrix
nesnesini
alacak
ve birazdan
detaylı inceleyeceğiz
fonksiyonun geri dönüş
değeri de
yine
c out nesnesinin
kendisini
döndürebilmemiz
için
stream nesnesinin
kendisini
döndürebilmemiz
için
arkadaşlar
fonksiyonun geri dönüş
değeri de
o stream referans
olacak
şimdi bakın
kod legal
bu arada
aslında
operator
overloading
referans
semantiğinin
zorunluluğunu da
ortaya koyan
bir örnek
yani
bu yerine
c'nin üstüne
bazı eklemeler
yaparak
ilk başta
en azından
c++
dilini oluşturdu ya
c'de sadece
pointer semantiği
var
ama bakın
sadece
pointer semantiği
ile
operator
overloading
mekanizmasını
implemente
etmeniz
mümkün değil
öyle değil mi
bir düşünün
arkadaşlar
sadece
adresleri
kullanıyorsunuz
e nasıl
bu mekanizma
olacak
hem
primitif
türlerle
bir
ilişki
bir çağrışım
alıksal bir çağrışım
oluşturmak istiyorum
ama
adres
operatorini
kullanmak zorunda
kalacağım
çünkü
fonksiyonların
parametresi
bu durumda
nesnenin
kendisine
erişmesi için
all by reference
olması için
pointer olması
gerekiyor
zaten
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
strostrup da
bir kitabında
bu
c++
dilinin
evolution'ı
kitabında
bunu anlatıyor
referans semantiği
olmasaydı
operator overloading'i
implemente etmek
mümkün olmazdı
yani c++
dilinin bazı
araçları
suskunsı olduğunda
onlar
referans semantiğini
esas alıyor
kullanıyor
öyle değil mi
pointer semantiğiyle
onları yapmak
bazı şeyleri
doğrudan yapmak
mümkün
ama örneğin
operator overloading'de
bu arayüzü
pointer semantiğiyle
oluşturmak
mümkün
değil
arkadaşlar
şimdi
burada
klasik
bu konuyla
ilgili
hem
üretimde
sık sık
karşımıza
çıkacak
hem de
böyle mülakatlarda
bize sorulabilecek
birkaç tane
klasik soru var
bu durumlar hakkında
biraz bilgi sahibi
olmalıyız
mesela
sorulardan
bir tanesi
close correctness
yani
operator overloading ile
const doğruluğu
arasındaki ilişki
const correctness
daha önce
değinmiştim
türçe'ye
const doğruluğu
diye
çeviriyorum
bir c++
kodunun
kalitesini
belirleyen
en önemli
faktörlerden biri
kodun
ingilizcesiyle
cause correct
olması
ben
kod review
çok yaptığım
için
çok sık
karşılaşıyorum
ileride ben
ödev verdiğimde
ödevler için
birlikte
kod review
yapacağız
arkadaşlar
böylece
kendi kodunuzda
ya da
başkalarının
kodunda
sizde
hataları
ya da kötü
yazım biçimlerini
görebileceksiniz
const correctness
gerçekten çok
çok önemli
hem
arkadaşlar
kodun
doğru çalışması
hem de
bazı durumlarda
sadece kodun
semantik
doğruluğundan
bahsetmiyorum
bazı durumlarda
const olması
gereken ödevleri
const yapmazsanız
örneğin
C++'ın
standart kütüphanesinin
en önemli birleşeni
STL
standart
template library
onu kullanırken
syntax hatası
alacaksınız
yani
ana ilkemiz ne
const olması
gereken her şey
const olmalı
arkadaşlar
mesela
const olması
const olarak
nitelenmesi
gereken
bir üye
fonksiyonu
bir member
const yapmazsanız
bu basit bir
hata değil
ben böyle hataları
kırmızı hata
red flag
olarak değerlendiriyorum
yine örneğinün
fonksiyonun
parametresi
const
my class
ref
olmak yerine
duruma göre
yanlışlıkla
my class
ref yapılırsa
bu çok ciddi
bir hata
nedense
programcılar
const
correctness
ile ilgili
kötü
yazımları
sanki çok
minör hataymış
gibi görme
eğiliminde
oysa çok
çok önemli
hata
yani artık
o da
neredeyse
güvenilmez
durumunda
kod
zaten
c++'taki
en önemli
problemlerden
biri de bu
o kadar
çok
karşılaşıyorum ki
herkes
sonuç odaklı
kod yazmaya
alıştığı için
öğrenmek için
biraz daha fazla
çaba göstermeye
çekindikleri için
arkadaşlar
çalışan bir
kodun
oluşturulmasını
yeterli
kabul ediyorlar
hatta
bazı şirketlerde
de durum böyle
ben de hep bunun esprisini
yapıyorum
kod çalışıyor
ama ortalık
kan görüyor
ama
kimse bir önlem
almamış
şimdilik çalışıyor
olması
onlar için
yeterli
hatta hatta
en az
4-5 tane
undefined
behavior'un olduğu
kodlarla
tek bir
kaynak dosyada
çok sık
karşılaşıyorum
undefined
behavior var
burada
diyorum
ama çalışıyor
cevabını
veriyorlar
o zaman
onları
kaderlerine
terk etmek
gerekiyor
başlarına
mutlaka ki
ileride bir
bela
gelecektir
şimdi biz
uzatmayalım
operatör
overloading'te
const
doğruluğu
arasındaki
ilişkiyi
görelim
arkadaşlar
şimdi bazı
operatörlerin
İngilizcesiyle
our team leader
doesn't know
what a
const
expert
is
arkadaşlar
bu çok sık
şanslanıyor
şimdi artık
eleştirmiyorum
ama
gerçekten de
C++'da
şu projeyi
yaptık
bu projeyi
diye övünenlerin
bazen
GitHub'da
da koyuyorlar
bakıyorum
yani yapmasan
daha iyi
o kadar kötü
kodlar ki
yani Allah'ın
herhalde
böyle bir
ne diyelim
özel bir
bahşetmesiyle
çalışıyor
o kod
yoksa
bakarsanız
ben çalışmasına
bile ihtimal
vermiyorum
ama demek ki
çalışıyor
iş görüyor
evet
hocam
Türkiye'deki
şirketler
ve durum
nasıl
ya çok iyi
gerçekten
C++'ı
çok iyi
kullanan şirketler
de var
yani şimdi
amacım
bu söylemle
şirketlerin
hepsini kötülemek
değil
yani gerçekten
çok çok iyi
ekipler de var
ama
ortalamaya
bakmak gerekiyor
şimdi ben
hiçbir firmayı
herhalde
iş ilişkisi
içinde bulunduğum
firmayı
eleştirecek
değilim
evet
hocam
hocam sizce
piyasadaki
şirketlerin
yüzde kaçı
usulüne
göre iş
yapıyor
yüzde 5
yüzde 10'un
üstünde
değildir
benim
şahsi
deneyimim
az da firma
tanımıyorum
peki
o zaman
konumuza
geri dönelim
arkadaşlar
mesela
toplama
operatörünü
düşünün
ya da
karşılaştırma
operatörlerini
düşünün
bu operatörler
bir
İngilizcesiyle
side effect'e
sahip değil
yani örneğin
böyle bir ifade
yazdığınız için
bu ifade
karşılığı
bir işlem
yapıldığı için
program state'inde
bir değişiklik
olmayacak
ne A
değişecek
ne B
ne X
değişecek
ne Y
o zaman
aslında biz
A artı
B yazmakla
bir fonksiyonun
çağrılmasını
sağlıyorsak
fonksiyonun
A'yı ve B'yi
değiştirmeme
garantisini
vermesi
gerekiyor
değil mi
ons doğruluğu
bu demek
bu da
örneğin
toplama
operatör
fonksiyonunun
diyelim ki
global operator
function
olması
durumunda
A'yı ve B'yi
yani
toplama
operatörünün
sol ve sağ
operantlarını
parametrelere
göndermiş
oluyoruz
e burada
tipik olarak
call by value
değil
call by reference
tercih ediyoruz
bazı durumlarda
call by value
da tercih edilebilir
dolayısıyla
call by reference
tercih ediyorsak
kesinlikle
const
l value
reference
olmalı
yani
const
matrix
ref
const
matrix
ref
burada
şunu anlatmaya
çalışıyorum
arkadaşlar
eğer ben
örneğin
bu fonksiyonu
bildirirken
ya da
tanımlarken
burada
const
anahtar
sözcüğünü
kullanmasaydım
semantik olarak
çok ciddi
bir hata
olurdu
okuyanları
yanıltırdı
const
nesneleri
bu fonksiyonlara
argüman olarak
gönderemezdim
bravo çağrı
r value'lar
bu fonksiyonun
parametresi olan
referanslar
r value'ya
bağlanamazdı
nokta
bunların hepsi
ve daha fazlası
dolayısıyla
eğer
argümanlar
değişmeyecekse
yani
operatörün bir yan etkisi yoksa
parametreler
tabi ki
eğer
referans
semantiği
kullanılıyorsa
const
l value
bir overloadingden
bahsetmiyorum
diyelim ki böyle
sadece bir tane
operatör artı var
sınıfın
üye fonksiyonu
olması durumunda
arkadaşlar
operatör
artı
yine fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri
matrix sınıfa
türünden olsun
e yine
bu fonksiyon
buraya dikkat
bu sefer
a artı b
gibi bir ifadede
ya da
m1
artı
m2
gibi bir ifadede
bu fonksiyon
m1 için
çağrılacak
m1'in
değişmeme garantisi
şüphesiz
üye fonksiyonun
const olması
öyle değil mi
ama
m1 artı
m2'de
sağ operandın
değişmeme garantisi
yine fonksiyonun
parametresinin
const
l value
referansı
olması demek
öyle değil mi
evet
aynı şekilde
unary operatörler
için de böyle
örneğin
lojit değil
operatörü
bir nedenden
sınıfa
eklenmiş
olsaydı
bu üye fonksiyonu
operatör
değil
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
boğul
olacaktı
yani
m1
matrix
nesnesi
diyelim ki
bir nedenle
şöyle bir
kullanım
gerekiyor
biraz doğal
durmasa da
burada
parametre
değişkeni
yok
ama
operatör
değil
logical
not
operatörü
bir
side
efekte
sahip
olmadığı
için
mutlaka
fonksiyonu
const
ve fonksiyon
yapmalısınız
bakın yine
tipik bir örnek
işaret
operatörleri
ben
işaret
operatörü
artıyı
matrix
sınıfı
için
kullanmak
isteseydim
ya da
işaret
operatörü
eksiği
işaret
operatörlerinin
bir side
efekti
var mı
yok
dolayısıyla
eğer bu
global
operatör
fonksiyonu
olacak ise
operatör
artı
parametresi
const
matrix
ref
olacak
arkadaşlar
ama
üye fonksiyonu
olacak ise
const
doğruluğu
bu kez
üye fonksiyonun
kendisinin
const
olarak
nitelenmesiyle
gerçekleştirilecek
anlaşıldı
değil mi
dolayısıyla
operatör
overloadingden
faydalanıyorsanız
mutlaka
const
doğruluğuna
dikkat etmelisiniz
üye fonksiyonlar
const
olacak mı
olmayacak mı
ama
mesela
arkadaşlar
başka bir örnek
operatör
atama
ya da
operatör
çarpma
diyelim ki
matematiksel tarafını
unutun
arkadaşlar
bir
int ile
belki
matristeki her bir
tam sayıyı
bir int
değerle
çarpılmasını
sağlayacağını
düşünün
int
parametreyle
operatör
çarpı
fonksiyonu
tabi ki
konsüye
fonksiyonu
olacak
ama
operatör
çarpı
eşit
fonksiyonu
yani
İngilizcesiyle
compound
assignment
operator
nesneyi
değiştiriyor
bu durumda
fonksiyonun
tabi ki
const
olmaması
gerekiyor
çünkü
artık bu
bir
mutator
anlaşıldı
değil mi
evet
yine örneğin
artı artı
önek
ya da
son ek
yani
increment
ve
dekrement
operatörleri
overload
edildiğinde
bu bir
mutator
olduğu için
üye fonksiyonsa
constüye fonksiyon
olmaması
gerekiyor
global
fonksiyonsa
fonksiyonun
parametresinin
bu sefer
lvalue
referansı
olması
gerekiyor
yani
const
lvalue
referans
olmayacak
şimdi
gelelim
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
türüne
burası
daha da
önemli
evet
yani
return
value
type
bilin
operatör
overloading
eleşim kuralları
fonksiyonların
geri dönüş
değeri
üstünde
bir
kısıtlama
yapmıyor
yani örneğin
bir operatör
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
türünü
int
yapabilir
miyim
syntactically
sentaksa
uygun
olarak
semantik
değil
yapabilirim
double
yapabilir
miyim
yapabilirim
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerini
sınıf
türü
yapabilirim
sınıf
türü
referans
yapabilirim
hatta
sınıf
türü
rvalue
referans
yapabilirim
hepsini
bu konuda
bir engel
yok
hatta
komik
olacak ama
fonksiyonu
void bir fonksiyon
bile yapabilirim
arkadaşlar
ama tabi ki
void bir fonksiyon
yaptığımda
o işlemden
elde edilecek
bir değer
olmayacak
o da
operatörlerin
hemen hepsi için
mantıksız bir
durum oluşturuyor
ama
dilim bu konuda
herhangi bir
engeli yok
mesela
int
operatör
artı
arkadaşlar
const
matrix
ref
e şimdi
çok saçma
bir matrisle
bir matrisi
topluyorum
ve bu toplamadan
bir tam sayı
elde ediyorum
bu semantik
olarak doğru
değil
ama derleyici
bana
neden böyle
bir operatör
fonksiyonu
yazdın
niye geri dönüş
değerini
int yaptın
diyecek mi
hayır
hatta hatta
arkadaşlar
void
yapayım
yine bir
sentaks
hatası
yok
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
ama
sentaks
hatası
olmaması
bu konunun
ya da
böyle bir
bildirimin
doğru olduğu
anlamına
gelmiyor
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
türünün
ne
olacağını
şüphesiz
problem
domenini
belirliyor
mesela
son derece
basit
karşılaştırma
operatörlerin
nasıl primitif
türlerde
boolean
türde
değer üretiyorsa
o zaman
örneğin
iki tane
stringi
karşılaştırma
işlemini
yapacak
operatör
küçüktür
fonksiyonunda
arkadaşlar
geri dönüş
değerinin
boolean
türden
olması
normal
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
yani
karşılaştırma
operatörlerinin
overload
edilmesinde
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
boolean
olması
son derece
doğal
bir durum
problem
domeni
belirliyor
x
intürden
bir
nesne ise
artı
x
ifadesi
yine
intürden
bir
nesnedir
o zaman
az önceki
metrik
sınıfındaki
operatör
işaret
operatörünü
düşünün
işaret
operatörünün
de
geri dönüş
değeri
yine
metrik
sınıfı
türünden
olmalı
doğal
olarak
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yani
fonksiyonların
geri dönüş
değerlerinin
ne olacağını
o sınıf
neyle
ilgili ise
o belirliyor
mesela
bir matrisle
bir matrisi
topladığımda
bir matris
elde ederim
bir matristen
bir matrisi
çıkarttığımda
bir matris
elde ederim
bakın
benim
ilerleyen
haftalarda
vereceğim
ilk kapsamlı
ödev olan
sınıf
tasarlama ve
implemente etme
ödevi
date sınıfı
bunun çok güzel
bir örneği
izleyin
ödevimizde
yani
sizin yazmanızı
istediğim
sınıf
kodunda
date
türünden
nesneler
problem
domenindeki
adı üstünde
date'i
türçesiyle
tarih
değerlerini
tutan
nesneler
altını çizmesine
bakmayın
şöyle
kullanıldığını
düşünün
mesela
date
dx
arkadaşlar
alın
size bu
bir date
nesnese
bakın
operator
overloading'i de
çok güzel gösteriyor
mesela
demiştim ki
intüitif
olmalı
operator
overloading
mesela
intüitif
böyle bir sınıf için
böyle bir sınıfa
neler yakışır
operator
overloading'le
ilgili
arkadaşlar
mesela
şu doğal
duruyor mu
bir tarihe
bir tam sayı
eklemek
tam sayıda
gün olsun
tarihle
gün sayısını
toplarsam
o tarihten
o kadar
gün sonraki
tarihi elde
etmeliyim
bu bence
gayet
intüitif
öyle değil mi
o zaman
buraya örneğin
şöyle bir fonksiyon
koysaydım
şimdilik
member mı
global mı
ona bakmayın
operator artı
arkadaşlar
int
and days
geri dönüş değeri
örneğin
d türünden
olması
doğal
çünkü tarihle
tam sayıyı
topluyorum
tarih elde
ediyorum
öyle değil mi
arkadaşlar
evet
yine aynı şekilde
operator artı
eşit
yine
bir
tam sayı
alabilir
ama şimdi
şuna bakın
bu çok güzel bir örnek
operator eksi
bu da onun
çıkartması
mesela
bugünün
tarihinden
efendim
2345 gün
önceki
tarihi
bulmak için
client şöyle bir
ifade
yazabilir
böyle bir ifade
yazdığında
10. satırda
bildirilen fonksiyon
çağırılacak
ve o fonksiyon
geri dönüş
değeriyle
bize
Ağustos
tarihinden
gün önceki
tarihi
verecek
ama şimdi
şuna bakın
bu sizde
nasıl bir
çağrışım
yapıyor
date
today
dx
to
today
dx
sizce
en doğal
çağrışım
burada ne
bir tarihten
bir tarihi
çıkartmama
izin veriliyorsa
ne elde
ederim
bir tarihten
bir tarih
çıkartınca
tarih mi elde
ederim
yoksa
gün sayısını
elde etmek mi
daha doğal
çabak gün sayısı
o zaman
bakın
şimdi bu
dilin kuralıyla
alakalı
değil ki
bir
operatör
eksi
daha
koyuyorum
fakat
bu sefer
bunun
parametresi
const
date
ref
ama
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
int
çünkü
iki tarih
arasındaki
arkadaşlar
gün farkını
döndürecek
takip edebildik mi
tabii ki
operatör eksi
bu arada
constüya fonksiyonu
olmalı
operatör artı
constüya fonksiyonu
olmalı
ve yine bu
operatör eksi
bu da constüya fonksiyonu
olmalı
çünkü ortada
bir
mutation
yani bir nesnenin
değerini değiştirilmesi
bir side effect
söz konusu
değil
ama
operatör
overloadingi
bakın
hemen
burada da
örneklemiş olduk
bir tarihten
en gün
sonrasını
hesaplamak için
en gün
öncesini
hesaplamak için
ve iki
tarih arasındaki
farkı
bulmak için
peki
sizce
tarihler
date'ler
comparable
varlıklar mı
problem
domeninde
evet
hem eşitlik
karşılaştırması
son derece
doğal
yani iki
tarih birbirine
eşit
me
değil mi
sizin
iki tane
date nesneniz var
date
d1
d2
belirli bir noktada
bu iki nesnenin değeri
eşit mi
sorgulaması yapmak
istiyorsunuz
son derece
doğal
ikisi de
bugünün
tarihi ise
eşit
ya da
eşit değil
sorgulamasını
yapmak
istiyorsunuz
ama
sadece
eşit ve eşit
değil
sadece
eşit
ve eşit
değil
aynı zamanda
bunlar
relational
operator'larla
da
karşılaştırılabilir
mesela
tarihleri
tutan
bir dinamik
diziyi
küçük tarihten
büyük tarihe
doğru
sıralamak
ingilizce
sort etmek
isteyebilirim
dolayısıyla
sınların
hepsi
doğal ve
intüütif
l1-d2'ye
eşit mi
l1-d2
birbirinden
farklı
tarihler mi
hangi
tarih
daha önce
hangi
tarih
daha sonra
anlaşıldı
değil mi
şimdi
burada
önemli
bir nokta
daha var
fonksiyonların
geri dönüş
değeri
türüyle
ilgili
arkadaşlar
eski
c++
olsaydı
biz fonksiyonların
geri dönüş
değerini
tipik olarak
bir sınıf
türünden
yapmak
istemezdik
maliyeti
yüksekliğe
ama şimdi
aşıma
semantiyi
ve
bazı durumlarda
da
mandatory
copy
allusion
ve çoğunlukla
da
named
return
value
optimization
bir fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
bir sınıf
türünden
olmasının
durumunda
yüksek
bir maliyet
çıkartmıyor
ama
başka bir
nokta
daha var
şimdi
bazı
programcılar
şunun
yapılması
gerektiğini
düşünüyorlar
yine
matrix
sınıfına
geri dönelim
burayı biraz
dikkatli izlemenize
fayda var
diyor ki
iki tane
matrix
nesnesini
toplanmasını
sağlayacak
bir fonksiyon
operator
artı
matrix
arkadaşlar
hadi
const
matrix
rep
const
diyor ki
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
referans
olsun
şimdi
sadece
soruya cevap
vermeye
çalışın
arkadaşlar
sizce bu
iyi bir fikir
olabilir mi
yani
böyle bir
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
referans
olması
iyi bir
fikir
olabilir mi
cevap
hayır
asla
bir kere
şöyle bir
problem var
bakın
çok dikkatli izleyin
nedense bunu
programcı
görmüyor
başlangıçta
yeni öğrenenlerden
bahsediyorum
illa bir
referans yapma
tutkusu
diyorum ki
hadi kabul
referans
yapalım
kabul ediyorum
arkadaşlar
referans
bir nesnenin
yerine
geçen
nesne
değil mi
isim
değişken
değil mi
evet
peki
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri kime
referans
olacak
eğer
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
otomatik
ömürlü
bir nesne
ise
e zaten
ona referans
döndürmeniz
tanımsız
davranış
olur
pati öyle
değil mi
otomatik
ömürlü
bir nesneye
referans
dönemezsiniz
ki
bravo
dangling
pointer
referans
oluşur
ayan bravo
o zaman
şöyle bir
imkan yok
mesela
matrix
sınıfı
türünden
result
arkadaşlar
evet
ve
siz
toplam
değerini
bu değişkende
tutacaksınız
ama
burada da
return
result
diyeceksiniz
arkadaşlar
zaten
ana akım
değerli
işleri
hemen
otomatik ömürlü
nesneyle
geri döndüğünüz
referans
hematili
geri döndüğünüz
için
size
doğrudan
uyarı
mesajı
verir
değerli işlerin
çoğu
basit
kontrolü
yapıyor
o zaman
otomatik ömürlü
nesneye
referans
dönemem
ee
peki
sol operanda
referans
döndürsem
ya o da
saçma
sol operanda
nasıl
referans
döndüreyim
o zaman
eğer ben
sol operanda
bir referans
döndürseydim
m1 artı
m2
arkadaşlar
takip edin
bunlar
matrix nesneleri
olsun
e bu
m1'e
referans
öyle değil mi
e ben şimdi
tekrar
m3
dediğimde
e
tekrar
m1'in
değerini
kullanmış
olurum
hele hele
ifade içinde
bir
mutation
varsa
zaten
mantıklı
bir senaryonla
oluşma
şansı yok
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesneye
referans
verebilirsiniz
o en azından
tanımsız
davranış
değil
ama dinamik
ömürlü
bir nesneye
referans
dönerseniz de
o dinamik
ömürlü nesneyi
kim delete
edecek
o da saçma
dolayısıyla
hiçbir şekilde
böyle fonksiyonların
geri dönüş
değerini
l-value
referans
yapmaya
çalışmayın
siz ilgilendiren
şu olsun
her zaman
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
sınıf
türünden
olacak
bu tür
fonksiyonların
ama
maliyet
farkı
yok
canım
niye
maliyet
olsun
siz zaten
eğer
burada
bakın
birinci
ihtimal
eğer
return
statement
expression
geçen görmüştük
bir PR value
expression ise
zaten
mandatory
copy
illusion
olacak
arkadaşlar
efendim
sonucu tutacak
otomatik ömürlü
bir nesne ise
burada ne olacak
eğer
arkadaşlar
return value
optimization
named return value
bloke eden
bir senaryo
değilse
ki öyle bir iki
senaryo olabilir
bu örnekte değil
ama
o zaman
zaten
derleyici
named return value
optimization
yapacak
hadi onu da
yapamıyor
o zaman
ne olacak
kim söyleyecek
o zaman
ne olacak
hayır
sorumun cevabı
inline
değil
diyelim ki
bir nedenden
dolayı
named return value
optimization
yapılmıyor
söyleyin bakalım
bu otomatik ömür
bravo
sonat
yusuf
beklediğim cevap
bu
o zaman da
move
semantics
devreye
girecek
taşıma
semantiği
devreye
girecek
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yani fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerini
genel olarak
sınıf
türünden
yapmaya
çekinmeyin
bu
kötü değil
belki çok
seyrek durumda
kötü kabul
edebilir
arkadaşlar
şimdi eskiden
taşıma
semantiği
olmadığı zaman
biz
şunu yapıyorduk
yani ben
tabii
15 sene
10-15 sene
öncesinden
bahsediyorum
out parametre
kullanıyorduk
ama
out parametrede
tabiri caizse
dünyanın
çirkin şeyi
out parametre
ne demek
biliyorsunuz
diyelim ki
myclass
isimli bir sınıf
var
ve benim
fonksiyonum
myclass
sınıfı
türünden
hesapladığı
bir değeri
çağıran
koda iletecek
normalde
günümüzde
ne yapıyoruz
normal
ink döndürür
gibi
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerini
myclass
türü
yapıyoruz
ama
şimdi
daha önce
şöyle bir
kaygı
vardı
belki
10-15
sene
önce
ya da
belirli durumlarda
böyle bir
kaygı
vardı
deniyordu ki
ya bu
duruma göre
yüksek maliyet
oluşturabilir
o zaman
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerini
bu amaçla
kullanmayalım
fonksiyonun
parametresini
l value
referans
yapalım
ki o zaman
zaten
r value
referans
yoktu
işte
foo'yu
çağıran
nasıl
çağıracak
buradan
bir
myclass
nesnesi
istiyor
ama
önce
kendisi
myclass
nesnesini
oluşturuyor
işte
buna
alt
parametre
deniyor
programlamada
tipik olarak
foo'yu
çağırıyor
ve
m'yi
gönderiyor
böylece
foo
referans
semantiğiyle
aldığı
ya da
duruma göre
pointer
semantiğiyle
aldığı
yani
adresini
aldığı
nesneyi
o
çağıranın
beklediği
değerle
set ediyor
ama
şimdi
günümüzde
çok belki
kullanım alanı
çok çok
daralmış durumda
neredeyse
hiç
yani
alt parametre
halen
belirli durumlarda
kullanılıyor
ama
böyle bir senaryoda
sadece
tek bir değeri
iletmek için
arkadaşlar
artık alt parametre
kullanmak
şüpheli bir durum
kullanmamak
daha doğru
tabii ki
her zaman
istisnalar
olacaktır
yani
ben
her durum için
bir istisna
oluşturabilirim
böyle derken
ben hep
çoğunluk
senaryosu
derimini
kullanıyorum
çoğunluk
senaryosu
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
bir sınıf
türünden
olması
mesela
diyelim ki
fonksiyonumuz
bir dinamik
dizi döndürüyor
gidip de
zorlama
şekilde
sanki
maliyet üstünde
çok fazla
katkısı
olacakmış gibi
madem
koskoca
bir vektörü
döndürüyorum
o zaman
fonksiyonun
parametresini
stod
vektörün
int
açılma
türünden
bir
lvalue
referans
yapayım
buraya
vektörünü
göndersin
biz o
vektörü
set edelim
hayır hayır
bunun yerine
çok daha
doğal olanı
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
doğrudan
vektör olması
evet şimdi biz
operatör
overloading'e
geri dönelim
neyi
konuşuyoruz
neden
bahsediyoruz
hala
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
dilin
ortaya koyduğu
bir zorlama
dil ile ilgili
bir kısıtlama
değil
void bile
yapabilirsiniz
ama yapmanız
hemen her zaman
saçma olur
işte örneklerde de
göstermeye
çalıştığım gibi
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
türünün
ne olduğu
tamamen
problem
domainine
bağlı
ama
şunu
söylesek
arkadaşlar
yanlış
olmaz
operatör
fonksiyonlarının
arkadaşlar
bir iki
istisna
olabilir ama
çok büyük
çoğunlukla
geri dönüş
değerini
diskart
etmek
lojik bir
hata
yani şöyle bir şey
yapmak ister miyiz
bu iki
matriz
toplansın
eee
bakın
derleyici
böyle bir
ifade
yazdığınız için
size hiçbir zaman
uyarı mesajı
vermez
ama işte
modern
C++'da
dile eklenen
her yeni
C++
standardı
yeni
attribute'ler
ekliyor
attribute dediğimiz
niteliciler
vardı
o attribute'lardan
bir tanesi
çok önemli
neydi o attribute
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
diskart
edilirse
derleyici
uyarı
mesajı
vermeye
teşvik ediliyor
o attribute'un
ne olduğunu
hatırlayan var mı
bir derste
evet
no discard
dolayısıyla
örneğin
arkadaşlar
class
begin
lojik olarak
toplama operatör
fonksiyonunun
operatör artı
yine üye fonksiyonu
olduğunu düşünelim
const
begin
ref
ama
no discard
ben
atribütleri
inşallah
normalde
ileri C++
kursunda ayrıntılı
anlatıyorum
çünkü
bazı atribütler
biraz daha
avraması
zor
bir de
kursun süresi
de
maalesef
her şeyi
anlatmamıza
izin vermiyor
200 saat
ama
el ele atribütleri
da çok sık
kullanan
bu kurs
içinde
anlatacağım
tabi bu kadarla kalmıyor
mesela no discard
sadece fonksiyonları
nitelemek zorunda
değil
şunu da yapabiliyorsunuz
mesela bir sınıfı
no discard
olarak nitelerseniz
artık
herhangi bir fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri
o sınıf
türündense
arkadaşlar
o fonksiyona
yapılan çağrıdan
geri dönüş değeri
discard edilirse
yine derliği için
uyarı mesajı
vermeye teşvik ediliyor
evet o zaman
operatör artı
operatör küçük
arkadaşlar
hepsi olmasa da
çünkü bazı
operatörlerin
yan etkisi var
özellikle
yan etkisi olmayan
operatörlerin
ne olması
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
lojik olarak
no discard
atribütüyle
nitelenmesi
daha
doğru
evet
peki
şimdi
fonksiyonların
geri dönüş değeri
türünden de
bahsettik
parametrelerinden
ons correctness
dan bahsettik
efendim
referans semantiğinden
bahsettik
buraya kadar
her şey güzel
bir soru daha
sorayım
arkadaşlar
olsan diyor ki
hocam
class için
olan
syntaxı
gösterebilir
misiniz
ben de o
discardı
işte
şimdi bu
atribüt konusuna
çok fazla
girmek istemiyorum
o zaman
neden biliyor musunuz
orada tüm
syntaxı anlatmak
ciddi zamanıma
olur
bazı
atribütler
birden fazla
yerde
kullanılabiliyor
bazı atribütler
sadece tek bir yerde
kullanılabiliyor
şimdi onların
hepsini anlatmam
gerekiyor
o yüzden isterseniz
onu başka bir
derse bırakalım
benim amacım
burada sadece
semantik olarak
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerinin
kullanılmasının
lojik bir
semantik bir
mecburiyet olması
yoksa niye
iki tane tam sayıyı
toplayayım
arkadaşlar
bakın
gerçekten de
standart
kütüphane de
birçok fonksiyonu
node discardı
olarak niteliyor
mesela
kod anlamaya
çalışmayın
gerçi bu örneği
vermiştim
ama bir örnek
daha vereceğim
müsaadenizle
mesela bakın
container
sınıfları
vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
arkadaşlar
bazı fonksiyonlar
sadece
predikat
mesela
boş mu
yani
size sıfır mı
e
geri dönüş
değeri
bool
boolu
kullanmadım
şimdi bu fonksiyon
node discard
atribütüyle
nitelenmemiş
olsaydı
aşağıda
görebiliyorsunuz
umarım
bu uyarı
mesajını
derleyici
vermeye teşvik
edilmeyecekti
niye versin
herhangi bir fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değerini
discard edebilirim
yine bakın
size fonksiyonu
vektörde tutulan
öye sayısını döndürüyor
arkadaşlar
yine bakın
node discard atribütü
var burada
diyor
başka bir örnek
mesela
bazı durumlarda
node discard
olup olmamız
biraz
tartışmalı da olabilir
ben size bir örnek
daha vereyim
random kütüphanesi
rastgele sayı üreticisi
bunlara
random number generator
diyoruz
ya da
engine
diyoruz
ENG
şimdi bakın
bu sınıf
fonksiyon çağrı
operatörünü
overload etmiş
ki
önemli
alt başlıklarımızdan
biri olacak
ama
biz böyle bir çareyle
bir rastgele sayı üretiyoruz
zaten bu sınıfın
varlık denedir
rastgele sayı üretmek
fakat
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
buradan üretilen
rastgele sayıyı
kullanmadığım için
yine denleyici uyarı
mesajı verdi
evet
peki
şimdi fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değerine de
kapsamlı bir şekilde
değindik
arkadaşlar
önemli bir soruya
daha gelelim
bir operatörü
hocam
neco
Allah'ın izniyle
bir operatörü
overload etmek istiyorum
global mi olsun
yani free function mi olsun
member function mi olsun
şimdi bu sorunun
öncelikle net bir cevabının
olmadığını söyleyebilirim
yani
birden fazla kişi
çoğunluk senaryosu olarak
bazı
kural demeyelim de
ilkeler sunuyorlar
ama
sonuçta hiçbir ilke
mükemmel değil
dolayısıyla
ben şöyle
diyemem size
bu fonksiyonları
global yapın
böyle fonksiyonları
member yapın
diyemem
öyle bir durum olur ki
siz
onun dışına
çıkmak isteyebilirsiniz
yani
eğer
söz konusu
operatörün
global
operatör fonksiyonu
olmasında
bir sakınca yoksa
çünkü hatırlayınız
bazı
operatörler
global fonksiyonlarla
overload edilemiyordu
member function
olmak zorundaydı
işte fonksiyon çağrı
operatörü
subscript operatörü
member selection
arrow operatörü
gibi
ama onların dışında
mesela toplama
çıkarma
karşılaştırma
operatörleri
vesaire
bunlar
member da olabilir
global da olabilir
fakat
tek ilke olarak
söylemiyorum ama
birçok kişinin
uyduğu ilke
şöyle
dikkat
simetrik
operatörleri
global
operatör fonksiyonu
yapmak
ama burada
simetrik ne
anlama geliyor
yani onu
doğru anlamamız
gerekiyor
ben
operatördeki
simetriyi
şöyle anlıyorum
izleyin
x ve y
örneğin sınıf
nesneleri olsun
ya da biri
sınıf nesnesi
olsa
yeterli
sol olan
eğer
x artı
y yazmakla
y artı
x yazmak
aynı işleme
karşılık
geliyorsa
aynı soyutlama
ise
bakın
aynı değeri
üretiyorsa
demiyorum
o zaman
global
operatör fonksiyonu
tercih ediliyor
tipik olarak
anlaşıldı
değil mi
mesela
bunun en tipik örneği
arkadaşlar
matrislerin
toplanması
stringlerin
e
matris artı
matris
de matris
operatları
yer değiştirirseniz
de matris
ya da
string artı
c string
bir string
c string artı
stot string
yine bir c string
o zaman
global operatör fonksiyonu
en azından
standart kütüphane
buna uyuyor
ağırlıklı olarak
anlaşıldı
değil mi
arkadaşlar
simetrik operatörler
mesela simetrik operatörler
neler olabilir
aritmetik operatörler
karşılaştırma operatörleri
bunlar tipik
simetrik operatörler
bunların
global operatör
fonksiyonu
olarak yazılması
bir kural
değil
ama
başta standart
kütüphane
olmak üzere
daha iyi
bir tercih
olarak
görülüyor
ama
mesela
siz kendi
string sınıfınızı
yazıyor
olsaydınız
toplama operatörünü
üye operatör
fonksiyonu
olarak
tanımlasaydınız
ve bunun da
yaratacağı
sizin için
bir problem
söz konusu
değilse
kimse size
hesap soramaz
yani
o şekilde
izliyorsanız
yapabilirsiniz
şimdi
bazılarında da
şöyle bir eğilim var
kendi
kullandıkları
ilkeleri
arkadaşlar
bir
zorunlulukmuş
gibi sunuyorlar
sanki dilin kuralı
Allah'ın emri
illa böyle yapacaksa
onlara da fazla
iltifat etmemek
gerekiyor
mesela bunun
en tipik örneği
bu
coding
conventions
ya da
styling guides
o
10 tane
kodlama
ilkelerine ilişkin
kaynak göstereyim
birinin
x dediğine
öbürü
y diyor
yani biri bu kötü
bu iyi diyor
öbürü tam
dersi
bu kötü
bu iyi diyor
yani bunlar
arasında
ciddi
çelişkiler
olabiliyor
evet
ama
biraz erken
olsa da
genel
kodlama
ilkeleri
açısından
bence
birinci
başvurunuz
arkadaşlar
c++
core guidelines
olmalı
yani eğer
çalıştığınız
şirket
şu guideline'i
tercih edeceksin
diye bir
ne diyelim
size
instruction
vermemişse
bence
benim şahsi
fikrim
google'ın
amazon'un
şunun
bunun
değil
doğrudan
bu yerine
strostrup'la
herb satırın
başlattığı
ve günümüzde de
baya ilerlemiş
olan
c++
core guidelines
denilen
ve buna bağlı
bir de kütüphane
var arkadaşlar
onu
kullanın
derim
yani firmanıza da
onu
önerebilirsiniz
gerçekten
benim de
bakın
github
bc
çok geniş
her şeyle ilgili
isimlendirmeden
tutun
fons core
etnesa
kalıtıma
arkadaşlar
erişim kontrolüne
erişkin
her şey var
yani ben
kişisel olarak
benim tercih ettiğim
ilke seti
c++
core guidelines
ileride bunun hakkında
daha fazla konuşuruz
peki
o zaman şimdi
biraz
işin pratik kısmına
gelelim
bir sınıf
oluşturalım
bu sınıf için
operatör
overloadingden
faydalanacak
örnekler yapalım
önce
temel operatörlerin
overload edilmesini
görelim
bundan sonra
bir dahaki
derste
bazı
özel
durumları
olan
operatörlerin
overload edilmesini
ayrı bir alt başlıkla
her birini ayrı bir alt başlıkla
ele alacağız
mesela
inkrement
dekriment
operatörleri
bunlara
biraz
daha fazla
zaman harcamamız
gerekiyor
neden
tahmin edebiliyorsunuz
değil mi
çünkü bu operatörler
önek konumunda
da kullanılabiliyor
prefix
inkrement
operatörü
de var
postfix
inkrement
operatörü
de var
demek ki burada
dilin
bazı kuralları
olmalı
onun dışında
köşeli parantez
yani
subscript
operatörünün
overload edilmesi
arkadaşlar
içerik operatörünün
dereferencing
ve arrow
member selection
arrow
operatörlerinin
overload edilmesi
bunların her biri
ayrı bir alt başlığımızı
olacak
fonksiyon çağrı
operatörünün
overload edilmesi
tür dönüştürme
operatörlerinin
overload edilmesi
onların her biri
ayrı ve önemli
alt başlıklarımız
olacak
ama biz şimdi
en basit
örneklerle
başlayalım
arkadaşlar bu arada
bir soru
yine tahmin
sorusu
bilenler
lütfen cevap
vermesin
evet
diyelim ki
my class
diye bir sınıfımız
var
class my class
bakalım
tahminler ne olacak
bilgi değil
böyle soruları
neden soruyorum
aslında pekala
kural değişikliği
olabilirdi
bazı kurallar
matematik gibi değil ki
tasarımcının
isteğiyle
koyulmuş kurallar
peki
necati sorunuz var
soruyorum
my class
sınıfının
operatör
artı
fonksiyonu
var
arkadaşlar
int parametreli
my class
sınıfının
operatör
eşittir
fonksiyonu
var
yani
normal
copy
assignment
ve
soru
şu
my class
sınıfı
türünden
bir neslem
var
şimdi
şu fonksiyon
var olduğu
için
m
artı
gibi bir
işlem
yapabilirim
m artı
eşittir
diyebilir miyim
yani
atom operatör
fonksiyonu
overload
edilmişse
toplama fonksiyonu
da overload
edilmişse
artı
eşitte
otomatik
var oluyor mu
işte
bakın
ilginç
arkadaşlarımın
bir kısmı
evet dedi
oysa
cevap
hayır
yani
artıyı
ve eşitte
overload
etmeniz
artı
eşitte
overload
etmeniz
anlamına
gelmiyor
anlaşıldı
değil mi
artı
eşitin
overload
edilmesi
için
fiilen
artı
eşit
operatör
fonksiyonunu
bildirmelisiniz
bu bütün
işlemli
atom
operatör
fonksiyonları
için
geçerli
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yani
eksi var
eşittir
var
eksi
eşit
yok
eksi
eşitte
ayrı
olarak
ne yapmak
zorundasınız
overload
etmelisiniz
doğrudan
kodlamaya
geçmeden
önce
son bir
saptama
daha
arkadaşlar
Fatih
Akgül
eşit
ve eşit
değil
o
C++
20 ile
değişen
kural
ben de
tam
ondan
bahsedeceğim
arkadaşlar
bakın
şimdi
çok güzel
bir
soru
tam da
benim
bahsedeceğim
konuyla
ilgili
şimdi
proje
ayarlarında
C++
20'den
17'ye
alıyorum
yani
şu anda
C++
17'ye
göre
derlenecek
klas
neç
ne bir
ne iki
eşit
sentax hatası
çünkü
eşittir
equal
operatörünü
overload
eden
bir
fonksiyon
yok
operatör
public
bool
operatör
eşit
Fatih
const
neç
ref
const
şimdi
artık
15.
satırdaki
kod
legal
hale
geldi
çünkü
dilin
kurallarına
göre
derleyici
bu ifade
karşılığı
bu fonksiyona
çağrı
yapacak
buraya
kadar
tamam mı
ne bir
eşit
değil
ne iki
sentax
hatası
ama
bakınız
arkadaşlar
proje ayarlarını
C++20'ye
çekiyorum
bu kodun
geçerli olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
şimdi
C++20
operatör
overloadingde
çok önemli
bir
ekleme
yaptı
bu
maalesef
süre açısından
bu kursta
anlattığım
bir konu
değil
ama
biraz bahsedeyim
isterseniz
sadece
bahsedeceğim
arkadaşlar
her şeyden önce
dile
yeni bir
operatör
eklendi
bakın
dile
operatör
eklendi
böyle
radikal
değişiklikleri
dilin
mesela
yeni bir
kontrol
deyiminin
eklenmesi
yeni bir
operatörün
eklenmesi
böyle
radikal
değişiklikleri
standartta
sor
sintekse
ilişkin
değişiklikler
deniyor
bu
operatör
token'ı
arkadaşlar
bu olan
operatör
e şimdi
aslında
bu
operatörün
resmi olarak
formal
ismi
three way
comparison
operator
fakat
bir de
böyle hep
olur ya
informal
genel kabul
görmüş ismi
buradaki
token
uzay gemisine
benzetildiği
için
spaceship
operatörü
deniyor
arkadaşlar
ben
Türkçe'de
üç yollu
karşılaştırma
operatörü
diyorum
şimdi bu
apayrı bir
konu
böyle
bir iki
cümlede
anlatmam da
mümkün
değil
fakat
bu
operatörün
dile eklenmesiyle
bazı
temel
kurallarda
değişti
yani
bu
operatörün
dile eklenmesinden
önce
biz
klasik
olarak
comparable
equality
ya da
relational
comparable
sınıflar
için
altı tane
operatörü
ayrı ayrı
overload
ediyorduk
altı tane
operatörü
ayrı ayrı
overload
ediyorduk
altı tane
operatör derken
karşılaştırma
operatöründen
bahsediyorum
fakat
şimdi
bu
operatörün
dile eklenmesiyle
bu arada
standart
kütüphanede
de değişiklik
yapıldı
yani
c++20
öncesi
sınıfların
altı tane
operatör
fonksiyonunda
mesela
string sınıfı
böyleydi
vektör sınıfı
olduğunu
görürdünüz
fakat
c++20
ile
artık
sınıfların
altı tane
operatör
fonksiyonu
karşılaştırma
operatör
fonksiyonu
olması yerine
ya
sadece
bu var
ya da
bununla
birlikte
eşit eşit
var
ve
şöyle
kurallar da
getirildi
geçen
derslerden birinde
buraya gönderme
yapmıştım ama
kimsenin aklında
kalmamış
olabilir
fonksiyonların
default edilmesi
hatırlıyorsunuz
değil mi
demiştim ki
o derste
c++20
kadar
bir fonksiyonun
default
bildirimini
yapmak
sadece ve
sadece
sınıfların
special
member
fonksiyonları
için
söz konusuydu
ama
c++20 ile
örneğin
spaceship
operatörü de
artık
default
edilebiliyor
işte
burada
maalesef
kurallar
biraz
hem
karmaşık
özü basit
olsa da
hem de
anlatması
epey zaman
alıyor
o yüzden ben
c++20 ile ilgili
önemli araçları
ileri c++
kursunda
anlatıyorum
bu
operatörün
dileklenmesiyle
yapılan değişikliklerden
biri
Fatih
eşit eşiti
yazdığınız zaman
eşit değili
yazmanız
gerekmiyor
yani
derleyici
eşit değil
operatörünün
kullanıldığı
bir ifadede
onu
eşit eşit
operatörüne
dönüştürüyor
onun
lojik
değerini
alıyor
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yani
eşit değil
operatörü
şimdi
basit anlatmak
gerekirse
otomatik olarak
geliyor
diyebiliriz
o yüzden
sorunuza böyle
kapsamlı bir cevap
vermem gerekti
çünkü şöyle desem
eşit eşit varsa
eşit değil
var mıdır
vardır ya da yoktur
neye bağlı
standartın ne olduğuna bağlı
c++
20 önce
standartsa
yoktur
ama c++
20 ve sonrasıysa
vardır
diyebiliriz
arkadaşlar
sadece bir dakika
kaldı
o yüzden
uygulamaya
geçmiyorum
ama bir dahaki
derste
bir sınıf üstünden
fiilen
önemli operatörlerin
hepsinin
overload edilmesini
birlikte
inceleyeceğiz
ve ondan sonra
da dediğim gibi
bazı
operatörlerin
overload edilmesini
tek tek
göreceğiz
evet
peki
ben Necati Ergin
derse katıldığınız için
teşekkür ediyorum
bir dahaki hafta
görüşmek üzere
herkese
iyi çalışmalar
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar